Hello everybody! Happy Thanksgiving! Yes, very happy Thanksgiving. Right now, as you are listening to this, I am on my way to enjoy Thanksgiving with my family in St. Louis. I am going to sit at my mom's Thanksgiving table for the first time in a long time and I can't wait. That is so special. I love that, Jenna. I'm going to be with my sister and her family. I have one request for Thanksgiving and Josh knows what it is. I want his homemade chocolate meringue pie. It's so good. It's so good.
大家好！感恩节快乐！是的，感恩节非常快乐。此时此刻，当你们听到这段录音时，我正在去圣路易斯与家人一起过感恩节的路上。我将久违地坐在我妈妈的感恩节餐桌旁，我已经迫不及待了。这太特别了。我喜欢这样，珍娜。我将和我的姐姐及她的家人在一起。我对感恩节有一个要求，乔希知道是什么。我想要他做的自制巧克力蛋白酥皮派。太好吃了。太棒了。
You do a chocolate meringue pie for Thanksgiving. I do chocolate meringue pie whenever I can get it. My mom always makes pecan pie at Thanksgiving and she just gave us so many pecans. I went to Texas to see her and her trees are loaded down, Jenna. But listen, while you are celebrating, guess what you can do? What can I do, Angela? You can curl up and re-listen to Diwali. Yes, today we are re-running Diwali. We have our interview with Mindy Kaling, which was so fun.
感恩节你会做一个巧克力蛋白酥皮派。我只要能吃到巧克力蛋白酥皮派就会做。我妈妈在感恩节总是做山核桃派，她刚刚给了我们好多山核桃。我去了德克萨斯州看望她，她的树上挂满了山核桃，珍娜。但是听着，在庆祝的时候，你猜你能做什么？安吉拉，我能做什么？你可以蜷缩起来重温排灯节。是的，今天我们重播排灯节。我们采访了明迪·卡灵，非常有趣。
So fun. Jenna, as I re-watched Diwali, I remembered a deleted scene I did not share with everyone. Ooh. And I bring it up because remember a few episodes back, I listed all of Andy's nicknames? Yes. You got to hear it. At Cornell in my fraternity, my house name was Hubble because I was so good at finding a party. It was like a powerful space telescope. Okay.
太有趣了。珍娜，在我重新观看排灯节时，我想起了一个我没有和大家分享的被删片段。噢。我提起它是为了，还记得几集前，我列出了安迪所有的绰号吗？是的。你一定要听听。在康奈尔大学的兄弟会里，我的绰号是哈勃，因为我很擅长找派对。它就像一个强大的太空望远镜。好吧。
Okay. So add that to the list of Nard Dog and Nard Man. Boner Champ, Baby Wawa. Ace, Buzz and Puke. Iceman. And now we have Hubble. So, they're amazing. I just love this episode and I have to say a big part of it is the interview with Mindy. We reached out to Mindy to let her know we were revisiting this episode
好吧。所以把它加到纳德狗和纳德男的名单里。安全套冠军，婴儿娃。王牌，巴兹和呕吐物。冰人。现在我们有了哈勃。所以，太棒了。我只是喜欢这一集，我必须说很大一部分原因是对比尔·明迪的采访。我们联系了明迪，告诉她我们要重温这一集
in Ange. Mindy sent in the little clip. Hey, Office Ladies fans. This is Mindy Kaling. I hope you're having a great Thanksgiving and enjoy this rerun of Diwali. When you're done, you can catch my new show, The Sex Lies of College Girls, streaming now on HBO Max. But I didn't come here just to plug my new show. I came here to plug my old show. Diwali episode. Enjoy it. I hope you're eating a lot of food. Happy Thanksgiving. Happy Diwali. Yes, you guys. Mindy's new show is now streaming on HBO Max. And it was created by Mindy and a friend of mine, Justin Noble. You might know his name
在安吉。明迪发来了一小段视频。嘿，办公室女士的粉丝们。我是明迪·卡灵。希望你们过一个愉快的感恩节，并喜欢排灯节的重播。结束时，你们可以在HBO Max上观看我的新剧《大学性爱生活》，现在正在流媒体播放。但我来这里不只是为了宣传我的新剧。我是来宣传我的旧剧的。排灯节这一集。尽情享受吧。希望你们吃了很多东西。感恩节快乐。排灯节快乐。是的，伙计们。明迪的新剧现在正在HBO Max上播放。它是明迪和我的朋友贾斯汀·诺贝尔共同创作的。你可能知道他的名字
from Brooklyn Nine-Nine, but I did a pilot with him and Nicole Byer and Cat Dennings called The Bluffs. He's so much fun. So is Mindy. I can't wait to see this show. The reviews are amazing. Yes. Once again, guys. Sex lives of College Girls. And thank you, Mindy. We love you. And guys, one more plug before we get back into this episode. Office Ladies is having a huge Black Friday sale on all of our merchandise. These are great deals. And you can find it on OfficeLadies.com. And on Cyber Monday, we are offering free shipping on all of our domestic orders. You
来自《神烦警探》，但我曾和他、妮可·拜尔以及卡特·丹宁斯一起拍过一部试播集，名叫《峭壁》。他太有趣了。明迪也是。我迫不及待想看这部剧了。评论太棒了。是的。再次重申，伙计们。《大学性爱生活》。谢谢你，明迪。我们爱你。伙计们，在我们回到这一集之前，还有一个宣传。《办公室女士》正在我们的所有商品上进行盛大的黑色星期五大促销。这些都是超值的优惠。你可以在OfficeLadies.com上找到它。在网络星期一，我们将对所有国内订单提供免运费优惠。你
just have to use the code free ship at checkout. Okay. Lady, that's it. That's it. I think it's time. And have a great Thanksgiving, everyone. We'll be back next week with all new episodes. But for now, please enjoy Diwali. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
只需在结账时使用代码 free ship。好吧。女士们，就这样了。就这样。我想是时候了。祝大家感恩节快乐。我们下周将带着全新剧集回归。但现在，请欣赏排灯节。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hello, everyone. Hi, you guys. Welcome to Diwali.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享独家的幕后故事，只有两个亲历者才能告诉你。我们是办公室女士。大家好。嗨，你们好。欢迎来到排灯节。
I'm so excited for this episode, Jenna. Me too. It's a great episode, and we have a great special guest. I just want to get to it. All right. Well, this is Season 3, Episode 6. It was directed by Miguel Arteta and written by our special guest, Mindy Kaling. Woohoo! It's going to be very exciting.
我太期待这一集了，珍娜。我也是。这是一集很棒的剧集，我们有一位非常棒的特邀嘉宾。我只想马上开始。好的。那么，这是第三季第六集。由米格尔·阿塔塔执导，由我们的特邀嘉宾明迪·卡灵编剧。呜呼！这将非常激动人心。
Well, let's get to it. We are going to waste no time. I'm starting with a summary. Do it. In this episode, everyone from Dunder Mifflin attends a traditional Indian celebration of Diwali in honor of Kelly. Now, Ryan is going to meet Kelly's parents, who are really less than impressed with his commitment to their daughter.
好吧，我们开始吧。我们将毫不浪费时间。我从一个总结开始。做吧。在本集中，邓德米夫林的每个人都参加了为庆祝凯利而举办的传统印度排灯节。现在，瑞安将去见凯利的父母，他们对他对他们女儿的承诺实在不敢恭维。
Well, to be fair, he says, with extra money, he wants to travel and get like an Xbox or something. So, you know. Yes. He'll also be less than impressed. Meanwhile, Michael proposes to his girlfriend, Carol. Oh, Michael. Wow.
好吧，公平地说，他说，有了多余的钱，他想去旅游并买个Xbox之类的东西。所以，你知道的。是的。他也会不太满意。与此同时，迈克尔向他的女友卡罗尔求婚。哦，迈克尔。哇。
Oh, Michael. Michael takes a big step. In front of a lot of strangers. Yeah. So awkward. It's a bit of a crash and burn. So awkward. Pam enjoys herself for the first time as a single person, and Angela guards the shoes
哦，迈克尔。迈克尔迈出了一大步。在很多陌生人面前。是的。太尴尬了。有点一败涂地。太尴尬了。潘第一次作为单身人士享受生活，安吉拉看守鞋子
while eating some dry naan. Very dry naan. And over at the Stamford office, Jim, Andy, and Karen work late into the night and booze it up. Yeah. Yeager beister. I mean, what's that look? So gross.
一边吃着一些干馕。非常干的馕。在斯坦福办公室，吉姆、安迪和卡伦一直工作到深夜，并大喝特喝。是的。野格烈酒。我的意思是，那是什么表情？真恶心。
Andy is a maniac. I'm going to give you fast fact number one. This is a really special episode because The Office was the first American television comedy series to depict the Hindu festival of Diwali. I love that. Way to go, The Office. It aired November 2nd, 2006, and it was seen by 8.8 million people on the night that it first aired.
安迪是个疯子。我要给你说第一条快讯。这是一个非常特殊的日子，因为《办公室》是第一部描绘印度排灯节的美国电视喜剧系列。我喜欢这样。干得好，《办公室》。它于2006年11月2日播出，首播当晚有880万人观看。
And now it's been seen by how many people? I don't even know. Did you know what Diwali was, Jenna, when we got the script? Shelby B asked the same question, and I did not know about Diwali. Did you know about Diwali? I did, but I grew up overseas. You know, I grew up in Indonesia. Diwali has a very big Hindu population.
现在有多少人看过？我甚至不知道。珍娜，当我们拿到剧本时，你知道什么是排灯节吗？谢尔比·B问了同样的问题，我不知道什么是排灯节。你知道什么是排灯节吗？我知道，但我是在海外长大的。你知道的，我在印度尼西亚长大。排灯节有非常庞大的印度教人口。
So I had heard of Diwali, and I thought it was awesome that we were going to do an episode about it. Had you ever celebrated Diwali? I had never celebrated it, but myself, I went to an international school. They did recognize, you know, many holidays, and there was like a Diwali day. Yeah. Well, they do that at my kids' school now. They have a day where they celebrate Diwali, which I think is really cool, especially since
所以我听说过排灯节，我觉得我们将要做一集关于它的节目真是太棒了。你以前庆祝过排灯节吗？我从未庆祝过，但我自己去过一所国际学校。他们确实承认，你知道的，许多节日，并且有一个类似排灯节的日子。是的。好吧，现在他们在我孩子的学校里也这样做。他们有一个庆祝排灯节的日子，我认为这真的很酷，尤其是自从
I grew up not knowing about it. It is so beautiful, and it was so fun. I remember we were all really giddy. Of course, this meant we got to leave the office. That brings me to fast fact number two, Angela. Fan question from Juliet G and Phoebe Tomak. Where did you shoot the scenes when you were celebrating Diwali? Well, guess who I went to for the answer.
我是在不知道它的情况下长大的。它是如此美丽，而且非常有趣。我记得我们当时都非常兴奋。当然，这意味着我们可以离开办公室。这让我想到了第二条快讯，安吉拉。朱丽叶·G和菲比·托马克的粉丝提问。你们拍摄排灯节庆祝场景是在哪里？好吧，你猜我去找谁寻求答案了。
Does it rhyme with Shmentish Media? It does, and we have a sting for it. You do? Kenton. Kenton. Kenton. Kenton. Kenton.
它押韵于 Shmentish Media 吗？是的，我们为此有一个音效。你有的？肯顿。肯顿。肯顿。肯顿。肯顿。
Kenton. Kenton. Yes, Angela. That was sent in by Tyler Beckwith, and we love it, Tyler. Thank you for our Kentopedia stage. It is really great. It sounds like something out of like a 1980s action kind of movie. Exactly.
肯顿。肯顿。是的，安吉拉。那是泰勒·贝克维斯寄来的，我们很喜欢，泰勒。谢谢你的肯顿百科全书舞台。真的很棒。听起来像是某种20世纪80年代的动作电影。没错。
Well, Kentopedia told us that Diwali was shot at Grant High School. We shot most of the scenes in their gym, which is called Grant Hall. And we shot there at the end of August, and school was in session. They had just started up the school year. He said that we shot there for three full days, and we had to work around the school schedule because school was happening in the hallways. I have such a fond memory of our time shooting there because they parked our trailers facing sort of like a little field with some trees, and normally they were just in a asphalt parking
好吧，肯顿百科全书告诉我们，排灯节是在格兰特高中拍摄的。我们在他们的体育馆拍摄了大部分场景，体育馆叫格兰特大厅。我们在8月底在那里拍摄，当时学校正在上课。他们刚刚开始新学年。他说我们在那里拍摄了整整三天，我们必须配合学校的日程安排，因为学校在走廊里进行。我对我们在那里拍摄的时光有着如此美好的回忆，因为他们的房车停放得面对着一片带有一些树木的小田野，通常他们只是在沥青停车场
lot. And so I would open my door, and there'd be trees and grass, and Brian brought a football and we like tossed the football out in the grass, and I have such fond memories of this whole week. I remember it, too, for those exact same reasons. Well, this school is host to a lot of filmmaking, including Freaks and Geeks, Black-ish, Malcolm in the Middle, and True Blood, and I've got a little bit trivia for you. Yeah?
所以我会打开门，外面有树木和草地，布莱恩带了一个橄榄球，我们在草地上扔橄榄球，我对整个星期有着美好的回忆。我也记得，正是因为完全相同的理由。好吧，这所学校是许多电影制作的举办地，包括《怪胎与书呆子》、《黑人当道》、《左右做人难》和《真爱如血》，我给你准备了一点花絮。是吗？
Malora Hardin went to Grant High School. Get out of town. Yeah, we shot at her alma mater. Wow. I love that. It's like a true Hollywood kid. She is. All these things from her life right here.
麦露拉·哈丁去了格兰特高中。别开玩笑了。是的，我们在她的母校拍摄。哇。我喜欢这样。就像一个真正的好莱坞孩子。她是。她生活中的所有这些事情就在这里。
To me, I still feel like a transplant in some ways in Los Angeles. Still to this day, if I'm ever out and about and I see the Hollywood sign, I'm like, there's a Hollywood sign. Oh my God, it's a Hollywood sign. But if I drive by and I see a film crew filming something on the street, I get as excited as if they pulled up in my neighborhood in St. Louis as a kid. And I'm like, oh, what are they filming? Oh, look, I wonder what it is.
对我来说，在某些方面我仍然觉得自己是洛杉矶的异乡人。直到今天，如果我在外面看到好莱坞标牌，我都会想，那里有个好莱坞标牌。哦，天哪，是个好莱坞标牌。但如果我开车经过，看到一个电影摄制组在街上拍东西，我会像小时候他们在圣路易斯我的街区停下来一样兴奋。我会想，哦，他们在拍什么？哦，看，我不知道那是什么。
I wonder if we can find out who's the star. Yeah, I look. Like, I get that same reaction still. Yeah, me too. I drive by and I try to see, is there someone famous out there? Exactly. So true. Well, I'm going to move us along, Angela, because I know we want to get to our interview
我想知道我们能不能查出谁是明星。是的，我看了。就像，我仍然有那种反应。是的，我也是。我开车经过，试图看看，那里有没有什么名人？没错。太真实了。好吧，我要继续前进了，安吉拉，因为我知道我们想去采访
with Mindy. Fast fact number three, I said earlier this was directed by Miguel Arteta. Angela, I was such a huge fan of Miguel. When I found out he was going to direct this episode, this is the only episode he directed, I completely geeked out. Okay. What did you do? Did you go up to him?
明迪。第三条快讯，我早些时候说过这是由米格尔·阿塔塔执导的。安吉拉，我是米格尔的超级粉丝。当我发现他要执导这一集时，这是他执导的唯一一集，我完全变成了极客。好吧。你做了什么？你去找他了吗？
Were you dorky? What'd you do? Oh, Angela, I followed him around the entire week. We bonded. At the end of this week, I thought we were best friends and would work together forever on every future project. And I'm not going to lie. Every time there was like a script that I was sent or when I was trying to produce a
你以前很傻气吗？你都做过什么？哦，安吉拉，我整整一个星期都跟着他。我们建立起了感情。在这周结束时，我以为我们是最好的朋友，以后每一个项目都会永远一起合作。我不想撒谎。每次只要有剧本发给我，或者当我自己尝试制作一
movie myself, he was the first person I would go to because I was like, I'm literally like this guy is a genius. I love him. I love that. I didn't know you were like following him around everywhere. Oh, yeah. I wanted everything about him to rub off on me. So he had directed this little indie movie called Chuck and Buck written by and starring
部电影时，他就是我第一个去找的人，因为我觉得，我简直觉得这家伙是个天才。我太爱他了。我喜欢那样。我不知道你当时到处跟着他。哦，对。我希望他身上的一切都能对我有潜移默化的影响。所以他曾导演过一部名为《查克和巴克》的小成本独立电影，由
Mike White, who by the way, you're also obsessed, have stalked. Yeah, I know, I know that you stalked him. I got to work with him. And then that made me feel one step closer to Mike White, who I eventually managed to stalk and become, I became friends with Mike White. And then I eventually got to be in a Mike White movie starring Ben Stiller. And then after that happened, I was like, well, I can, I can now retire because I have worked with my, my idol.
迈克·怀特编剧并主演。顺便说一句，你也是个狂热粉丝，曾跟踪过他。对，我知道，我知道你跟踪过他。我有幸与他合作。然后这让我觉得自己离迈克·怀特更近了一步，我最终设法跟踪并成为了……我成了迈克·怀特的朋友。后来我终于有机会参演了一部由本·斯蒂勒主演的迈克·怀特电影。在这之后发生的事让我觉得，好吧，我现在可以退休了，因为我已经和我的偶像合作过了。
I wrote in my journal about this week. Do you want to hear what I wrote lady? Of course. I always want to hear about your journal. Your journal delights me. That's, it does. That's going to be your autobiography. A journal delights me by Jenna Fisher.
我把关于这一周的经历写进了日记里。你想听听我写了什么吗，女士？当然。我总是想听听你的日记。你的日记让我感到开心。真的，会的。那将会成为你的自传。《詹妮弗·法尔的日记让我开心》。
I wrote that and I wrote this. Me and the adorable Mindy Kaling are going to be doing really early morning interviews together on all the local NBC stations. We are going to talk to 16 cities and we have to get up at 5 a.m. Oh my gosh, you guys did a little press junket. I think this is my very first one. Well, what's crazy about that, Angela, is you probably then after you were done had to come to work.
我写了那个，我还写了这个。我和可爱的明迪·卡灵将要在当地所有的NBC电台上一起做非常早的早间采访。我们要去16个城市进行访谈，而且我们必须在早上5点起床。哦天哪，你们做了一个小型媒体宣传之旅。我想这是我的第一次。好吧，那最疯狂的地方在于，安吉拉，你可能在采访结束后还得去工作。
Oh yeah, because they, we had to, I remember we had to be on stage. We actually did them on the set with the set as the background. And we got there and we met this satellite media tour is what they called it. And we met their crew and we had to be there at 4 a.m. to go through hair and makeup. And then we started doing interviews at 5 a.m. and we talked to a new city every 15 minutes for three hours. Wow. And that, you did it with Mindy.
哦对，因为我们得……我记得我们必须在舞台上。我们实际上是在片场做的采访，以片场为背景。我们到了那里，遇到了他们所谓的卫星媒体之旅剧组。我们凌晨4点就得去弄发型和化妆。然后我们在早上5点开始采访，每15分钟连线一个新的城市，持续了三个小时。哇。而且你是和明迪一起做的。
Mindy was my first press junket. Well, this is a wonderful segue into our upcoming segment. We'll take a break, but when we come back, we're going to play our interview with Mindy Kaling. She came and talked to us. It was amazing. It was such a joy to have her here and I'm so excited for you guys to listen to this. And then afterwards, we're going to fully break down the episode.
明迪是我的第一次媒体宣传之旅。好吧，这是一个很好的过渡，通向我们即将到来的环节。我们要休息一下，但当我们回来时，我们将播放对明迪·卡灵的采访。她来和我们聊了聊。太棒了。有她在这里真是太高兴了，我非常期待大家收听这段采访。之后，我们将全面剖析这一集。
We'll get to that right after the break. We'll see you with Mindy. Mindy Kaling. Hi. Hi guys. Hi. I'm so happy to be here. Welcome to office, ladies.
我们会在休息之后马上讲到那个。一会儿见，明迪。明迪·卡灵。嗨。嗨，大家好。嗨。我太高兴能来到这里了。欢迎来到《办公室女士》。
I'm giving you a hug through the Zoom user. Thank you. Congrats, you guys, on the massive success of this. This is like, this is awesome. This is everyone in my life is obviously such a fan and I'm like, I'm so proud of you guys. This is so great. Thank you. Thanks Mindy.
我通过Zoom隔空给你一个拥抱。谢谢。祝贺你们，这档节目取得了巨大的成功。这简直是……这太棒了。我生活中的每个人显然都是超级粉丝，而我……我为你们感到骄傲。这太棒了。谢谢。谢谢明迪。
Yeah, of course. We love it. We're having a good time. It's fun to hear the way that the show was through your guys' eyes because it's so loving and fun and super accurate and I like, I'm really enjoying it. So this is great. Thanks for having me. Thank you.
对，当然。我们很喜欢。我们过得很开心。听到你们眼中的节目是怎样的感觉很有趣，因为它充满了爱、乐趣而且超级准确，我真的很享受。所以这太棒了。谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢你们。
That was so nice. I feel like this is all just pure joy. I'm just so delighted to see you and to talk to you in this such a fun episode. So we just get to reminisce a little bit. Love it. Well, before we get into Diwali, we always like to ask all of our guests their office origin story. So how did you come to be on the show?
太美好了。我觉得这一切都纯粹是快乐。看到你并在这个非常有趣的剧集中和你交谈，我感到非常高兴。所以我们只是回顾了一小段过去。太棒了。好了，在我们进入排灯节这一集之前，我们总是喜欢问所有嘉宾他们的办公室起源故事。那么你是怎么加入这部剧的呢？
Well, it was 2004 and I had, I was off doing a play off off Broadway in New York called Matt and Ben, which was a play that I wrote with my writing partner and friend at the time, Brenda Withers, where it's like an hour long short play where I play Ben Affleck and she plays Matt Damon. It's so hard to tell this story without being like, just being like, okay, so just ignore that kind of interesting fact and move on. But so we did that. It won the Fringe Festival, got some attention and sort of was our entree to LA.
嗯，那是2004年，我在纽约外百老汇出演了一部名为《马特与本》的戏剧，那是我和当时的写作搭档兼朋友布伦达·威瑟斯一起创作的一部剧，大概有一个小时的短剧，我在里面扮演本·阿弗莱克，她扮演马特·达蒙。讲这个故事时如果不说“好吧，就忽略这个有趣的事实继续讲吧”就会非常难。但我们确实演了。它赢得了边缘艺术节的奖项，受到了一些关注，某种程度上成了我们进入洛杉矶的敲门砖。
And when we were in LA, I had like an arrested development spec and then that play. And I had very few meetings, the climate for hiring writers, if you were like an untested Indian American woman, it was very different 16 years ago than it is now. And the only place that I got an interview at, I got two interviews. One was at Nevermind Nirvana, which was a pilot about an Indian family. And I was like, yes, I could, yes, I could write on that show. And the other one was the office. And I remember Joey was like, do you guys remember how huge Joey was when we started
当我们在洛杉矶时，我有一个《发展受阻》的剧本大纲，还有那部戏剧。我几乎没有什么会议，对于雇佣编剧的环境来说，如果你是一个未经检验的印度裔美国女性，16年前的情况和现在非常不同。我唯一获得面试机会的地方，我得到了两次面试机会。一个是《尼尔瓦那别介意》，那是一部关于一个印度家庭的试播集。我想，是的，我可以在那个节目上写作。另一个是《办公室》。我记得乔伊当时……你们还记得我们开始拍摄时乔伊有多火吗？
shooting? Yeah. Oh yeah. The friend's spinoff. It was like the NBC. I think they put all their money in that. And then Father of the Pride. Do you guys remember that one?
对。哦对。《老友记》的衍生剧。就像是NBC的王牌。我想他们把所有的钱都投在那上面了。还有《父辈的荣耀》。你们还记得那个吗？
No. Father of the Pride was a cartoon, a Jeffrey Katzenberg produced cartoon about from the point of view of two tigers that worked with Sink Freed and Roy. Oh, yes. What? Yes. It's coming back to me. And it was an animated show.
不。《父辈的荣耀》是一部动画片，由杰瑞米·卡森伯格制作的动画片，视角是一只和齐格弗里德与罗伊一起工作的老虎。哦，是的。什么？对。我想起来了。那是一部动画节目。
This sounds like a bit on Saturday Night Live. Yeah. This doesn't sound like a TV show. Not only was it a real show, it was like the hottest show. Like you could not get an interview. So I didn't get an interview on Will and Grace. I didn't get an interview at Joey and I didn't get an interview at Father of the Pride. And you can imagine, like just to show how things have become so different from them,
这听起来像是《周六夜现场》里的一个段子。对。这听起来不像是电视剧。它不仅是一部真实的剧，而且是最热门的剧。就像你根本拿不到面试机会一样。所以我没有得到《威尔和格蕾丝》的面试机会，没有得到《乔伊》的面试机会，也没有得到《父辈的荣耀》的面试机会。你可以想象，这足以说明情况和现在有多么不同，
like can you imagine like now like a minority woman who won the Fringe Festival coming out to LA, not getting a meeting on like on all the two shows. So these have changed a lot. So that's great. But the two people who I got interviews with nevermind Nirvana and I went into their offices in Burbank. This has never happened to me before, but I sat in the office and as I was there waiting to meet the showrunner, they got the call that the pilot hadn't been picked up to series.
就像你能想象现在一个赢了边缘艺术节的少数族裔女性来到洛杉矶，却连两部剧的会都约不上吗。所以这些变化很大。这挺好的。但我拿到面试机会的两家公司，一家是《尼尔瓦那别介意》，我去了他们在伯班克的办公室。这以前从未发生在我身上，我坐在办公室里等待见剧集运作人时，他们接到电话说试播集没有被预定为整季。
So I sat there and then the assistant came out and was like, you should go home. Like there's no jobs. So I just like got up and left. And then the second one was at the office with Greg Daniels. And so I met with him and just so you know, my agent at the time who I won't mention was really like, yeah, this show doesn't have a lot of heat. Like I don't think it's really going to do anything. Everyone likes the British one better.
所以我坐在那儿，然后助理出来说，你应该回家了。这里没有工作。于是我只好站起来离开了。第二家是《办公室》和格雷格·丹尼尔斯。所以我去见了他，而且你们知道的，我当时的经纪人（我不会说是谁）真的说，这节目热度不高，我觉得它不会有什么大作为。每个人都更喜欢英国那个版本。
So it's just like, you know, it's good to meet Greg Daniels. He's like done a lot of good stuff, but like it's just good. It's just good to like have a general. So I went in there and there was not a lot of stakes and I had a, um, a very, a really fun interview with Greg that lasted two hours, but you guys know Greg. So it was actually probably only 15 minutes of talking in two hours. And, uh, and then he hired me and, um, or he didn't, he didn't hire me in the meeting. Like they still had to do up fronts and everything, but we had a great meeting and I heard it
所以就当是，你知道的，去见见格雷格·丹尼尔斯挺好的。他做过很多不错的东西，但这就当是……就当是去见个面聊聊。所以我去了那里，没有什么压力，我和格雷格进行了一次非常有趣的面谈，持续了两个小时，但你们了解格雷格。所以实际上大概只有15分钟在谈正事，聊了两个小时。然后，他雇用了我，或者他当时在会上并没有雇用我——他们还得做广告预售等等，但我们谈得很开心，我听说
went well. And then like a month and a half later I was told I was coming back for six episodes, such a small first season. But I was so new and I think you guys were, you know, new enough too that it was just like, Oh my gosh, any episodes, that's fantastic. Not knowing that that was kind of an unusually small number of episodes, but that was, that was how I got on the office. And how did you end up then playing a role on the show?
进展顺利。然后大约一个半月后，我被告知我将回来拍六集，第一季真是太短了。但我太新了，我想你们也足够新，所以感觉就像是，哦天哪，哪怕只有几集也太棒了。完全不知道这其实是一个异常小的集数，但这就是我加入《办公室》的方式。那么你后来是怎么在剧中扮演一个角色的呢？
You know, he had put, Greg had put into the contract, these acting, these writing contract, these acting clauses for, I think a number of the writers, at least it was in mine. And I think Paul Lieberstein's, so I guess in the back of his mind, he was thinking in those terms, but the first season classic episode, diversity day written by the great BJ Novak, um, I remember in the room, he loved this idea, Greg loved this idea of Michael Scott offending all these people, but it's like, it's, it's kind of the funniest version of it when there's like some minority people there too, who can get extra offended. So at that time, I think it just made sense to have another minority person.
你知道的，格雷格在合同中加入了一些表演条款，这些写作合同中的表演条款，我想是针对好几个编剧的，至少在我的合同里有。我想保罗·利伯斯坦的也有。所以我想在他的脑海里，他已经在朝这个方向考虑了。但在第一季的经典剧集《多元化日》中，由伟大的B·J·诺瓦克编剧，我记得在编剧室里，他非常喜欢这个点子，格雷格喜欢迈克尔·斯科特冒犯所有这些人的这个点子，但如果现场还有一些同样会感到被严重冒犯的少数族裔的话，这会是其中最好笑的版本。所以在那个时候，我觉得再加入另一个少数族裔角色是很合情合理的。
And I was like, I'll do it. I actually, I didn't volunteer, he's like, we, I had two lines in that episode and he said, do you want to be in it? And I was like, of course. And so diversity day, yeah, thank heavens that was the second episode because then that I guess starred then and I think maybe once or twice that first season, I wasn't in it very much. And then second season was like, I sort of saw, I got more lines.
当时我想：我来演。其实，我并没有主动请缨，他说我们……我在那一集里只有两句台词，他问你想不想参演，我说当然。所以《多元化日》……是的，谢天谢地那是第二集，在那之后我开始演了，我想可能在那第一季里有一两次，我的戏份不是很多。到了第二季，我发现自己有了更多的台词。
And yeah, that's how it happened. What blew me away, Mindy, is when I think back on that and I was, I was sort of reading back on, you know, Wikipedia about all of us and where we are at in our lives at that time and you were 24. And that blows my mind. You had your act together for, to me, for someone at 24, you, you, you were amazing because at 24, I was, I think I was doing takeout at Chin Chin's, I wasn't a waiter, I was just doing a hostess job.
是的，事情就是这样发生的。让我感到震惊的是，明迪，当我回想这件事时，我当时在维基百科上翻阅关于我们所有人以及我们在那个时候人生所处阶段的信息，而你当时才24岁。这让我大为震撼。在我看来，对于一个24岁的人来说，你把一切都处理得井井有条，你太棒了，因为在我24岁的时候，我想我大概在中餐馆打包外卖，我当时甚至不是服务员，我只是做迎宾的工作。
Do you know, you know what it is? Well, thank you for saying that. I mean, I love to feel like I was a wonderkin, but do you know what it is? Is that it's just the life of a writer, a comedy writer in the life of an actor. They're just so, they're so different, right? Like it's so, it's very hard to break into comedy writing, but I do think that is easier than breaking into acting because if you can write, you can write your own opportunities and write a spec script that, you know, then you can use and send out where it's like when
你知道吗？谢谢你这么说。我的意思是，我很乐意觉得自己是个神童，但你知道这是为什么吗？这是因为编剧的生活、喜剧编剧的生活和演员的生活，它们太不相同了，对吧？比如，跨入喜剧编剧这一行很难，但我确实认为这比跨入演员这一行要容易，因为如果你会写作，你就可以自己创造机会，写一个剧本大纲，然后你可以用来四处投递。相比之下，
you're a young actor, you're like, I just hope someone calls me in to see something. So thank you for saying that. But you know what? Also it felt less special because BJ is there and he was the same age and he'd already written on a show at 24, so it's just when I was like, oh, I guess I'm like young and cool. He was like, oh yeah, I've already worked on, he was on a Bob Saget sitcom and Mike Sher was like 28 and it already had like an Emmy and been an SNL for nine years or something crazy.
当你是一个年轻演员时，你会想：我只希望有人叫我去试镜。所以谢谢你这么说。但你知道吗？这也让人感觉没那么特别，因为B·J·诺瓦克也在那儿，他和我同龄，而且他在24岁时就已经在一档节目里当过编剧了，所以当我心想，哦，我猜我大概又年轻又酷吧？他却说：哦，是的，我已经在……他曾在鲍勃·萨吉特的情景喜剧里工作过，迈克·舒尔当时28岁，就已经拿过艾美奖，还在《周六夜现场》干了九年还是什么的疯狂经历。
There was no sense of like, you could ever think you were special or like ahead of the curve or anything like that with that group of people. Well I always thought you were special. Thank you. Thanks, Angela. All right, should we get into this episode, Jenna? Yeah. Yes.
在那群人当中，你绝对不会觉得自己有什么特别，或者走在时代前沿之类的。嗯，我一直觉得你很特别。谢谢你。谢谢你，安吉拉。好了，我们要开始聊这集了吗，珍娜？嗯。是的。
Did you get a chance to re-watch it? Yes, I did. What was it like for you to re-watch it? I have to say, I feel really lucky that Greg wanted to do this episode because it feels like now, you know, Angela was on my most recent show and we did an episode about Ganesh Pooja and there's so much more, you know, there's so many more shows on the air with like diverse cast and everything, but the fact that on primetime television and I don't know, what year did it come out, 2007 maybe?
你有机会重温这一集吗？是的，我看了。对你来说，重温这一集是什么感觉？我必须说，我觉得格雷格想拍这一集我真是太幸运了，因为感觉现在，你知道的，安吉拉参加了我最近的节目，我们做了一期关于象头神节的节目，你知道的，现在电视上有很多演员阵容更多元化的节目，但是，在黄金时段的电视上——我不知道，这是哪一年播出的，大概是2007年吧？
It aired November 2nd, 2006, it was seen by 8.8 million people and it was the first American television comedy series to depict the Hindu festival of Diwali. It was the very first one. That's cool. Yeah. That's amazing. Go us for doing that. And you know, the show Mindy's referring to is Never Have I Ever.
它于2006年11月2日播出，有880万观众收看，这是美国第一部描绘印度排灯节的电视剧喜剧。这是第一部。太酷了。是啊。太棒了。为我们的成就点赞。而且，你知道的，敏迪提到的那部剧就是《好想做一次》。
Mindy, I do want to give it a little plug here because it's so great and the cast is great and you're with them from the beginning. The young actors you got, I felt 100 years old on that set. So did I. So did everyone. So did everyone who was in 17. Oh my God. And they were so cute and they love the office so much.
敏迪，我真的想在这里为主创团队打个小广告，因为它真的太棒了，演员阵容也很棒，而且你从一开始就和他们在一起。你们找的那些年轻演员，我在那个片场觉得自己有一百岁了。我也是。所有人都是。17岁时的每个人都是。哦，天哪。而且他们太可爱了，他们超喜欢《办公室》。
Oh my gosh. They were so starstruck by you, Angela, it was so special that you got to be there. Oh my gosh. Mindy, what is the name of the lead actress on that show? Maitreya Ramakrishnan. I adore her. Oh. Because when you watch the show, you are so immediately in with her journey.
哦，天哪。他们见到你时简直惊为天人，安吉拉，你能去现场真的是太特别了。哦，天哪。敏迪，那部剧的女主角叫什么名字？麦特雷伊·拉玛克里斯南。我太喜欢她了。哦。因为你看这部剧的时候，你会瞬间融入她的旅程。
Yeah. Immediately. She is so like effervescent and open and just, wow. What a find. What a find. Thank you. She's going to flip out. Jenna, she's the office is her number one favorite show.
是的。瞬间融入。她整个人充满活力、思想开放，简直是——哇。真是个宝藏女孩。真是个宝藏女孩。谢谢。她肯定会激动得尖叫的。珍娜，她是《办公室》的头号铁粉。
If you go on her social media for more than two days, there's like an office meme or there's like, yeah, I bet you've been on her Instagram like with like, please, like, please don't throw trash at me. Like, just like some, some like famous Pam line. Okay. So, so here we go. So now we have Diwali, the festival of lights. It's on network TV.
如果你翻看她超过两天的社交媒体，就会发现里面有一个《办公室》的梗，或者有类似这样的内容——我打赌你一定去过她的Instagram，上面写着类似“求求你，请不要朝我扔垃圾”之类的话，就好像是帕姆的某句名言。好吧，所以——所以我们开始吧。现在我们迎来了排灯节，也就是光明节。它在主流电视台播出了。
Mindy, you have been so amazing at just really, I feel like representing all different sides of culture and on television. It's just, you should know what it's meant to people. We had a lot of people write in about having their community seen in this mainstream way, what it meant to them. It's, it's really moving. Oh, wow. That's so nice.
敏迪，你在电视上真正——我觉得——代表了文化的各个不同方面，这一点做得太棒了。真的，你应该知道这对大家意味着什么。我们收到了很多人的来信，谈到看到自己的社群以这种主流的方式呈现出来对他们意味着什么。这真的、真的很感人。哦，哇。太暖心了。
I mean, you know, the, one of the harder things about when you write the Diwali episode is like, we couldn't believe that Greg said yes, because normally we would do like a Halloween episode at that time of year because it's the end of October. But then I, when he said yes, I had to kind of confront the fact that I'm Indian American. I don't know very much about the holiday. And the, that experience of being Indian American and talking about how you don't know very much about the holiday kind of became a big part of the episode, which I loved. I didn't, I liked that Greg thought that was just as interesting, if not more interesting
我是说，你知道的，当你编写排灯节那一集时，比较困难的事情之一就是，我们简直不敢相信格雷格会答应，因为通常在一年中的那个时候我们会拍万圣节特辑，因为那是10月底。但后来，当他答应时，我不得不面对这样一个事实：我是美籍印度人，但我对这个节日其实并不是很了解。而那种作为美籍印度人、却发现自己对这个节日知之甚少的经历，某种程度上成了那一集的核心内容，而我非常喜欢这一点。我不讨厌——我喜欢格雷格觉得这同样有趣，甚至比——
than me going and like pretending that like my family and I were these experts at Hindu holidays and everything. So I really liked that Kelly is, is, has this defiant attitude about it, that it's really important while also not knowing anything about it at all. Yes. Except that she gets to wear a like an outfit that has some sparkles on it. Yes. Yeah.
假装我和我的家人是印度教节日专家的那一套更有趣。所以我真的很喜欢凯莉身上带着的那种挑衅态度——她对这个节日一无所知，但又觉得它非常重要。是的。除了她可以穿一套带亮片的衣服。是的。是啊。
Exactly. And the music part, she's really excited about that. Yeah. And Michael in the cold open, I mean, Mindy, I love whenever Steve would do an impression of us as our characters. Yeah. And so Michael's like, well, if you ask Kelly, it's like blah, blah, super fun. Yes.
没错。还有音乐部分，她对此超级兴奋。是的。还有片头前的搞笑桥段，我是说，敏迪，只要史蒂夫模仿我们演的角色，我都超爱。是的。所以迈克尔就会说，嗯，如果你去问凯莉，就会觉得blah blah超好玩。是的。
I know. And he didn't get to do that that much, right? Like I felt like that he didn't do impressions of us too, too much. When he did, I just, it just got me so tickled. I know. It was so funny. I have a gazillion things I want to say, Jenna, but go, go, you go. One of my favorite lines in this whole episode is this, how long have you been married to
我懂。而且他没机会经常这么做，对吧？我觉得他模仿我们的次数其实并不多。每当他这么做时，我都觉得被戳中了笑点。我懂。太搞笑了。珍娜，我有一大堆话想说，不过你先来，你先来。整集中我最喜欢的台词之一就是这个：你跟那个啦啦队长结婚多久了？
the cheerleader? And that was your dad. Oh my gosh. To this day, my dad gets checks from, he gets residual checks. It's like his, the thing he's the most proud of. Oh, from the office? Yes. From the office, right?
那是你爸爸。哦，天哪。直到今天，我爸爸还会收到支票，他能收到重播版权费支票。这就像是他最引以为傲的事情。哦，从《办公室》来的？是的。从《办公室》来的，对吧？
Yeah. And one time he was with my stepmom at Erawon and they got stopped and someone was like, you are in the office, weren't you? And that was like early when they were dating before they got married. And my dad was like, felt so cool about it. So yeah. And that was like some good street cred right there. Yeah.
对。有一次他和我的继母在埃拉旺（Erewhon）超市，结果被人拦下来，对方说：“你演过《办公室》，对吧？”那是他们刚开始约会、还没结婚的早期。我爸爸当时觉得酷毙了。所以，是的。那就像是获得了一些很棒的街头声誉。是啊。
I'm being recognized. Yeah. Completely. I just remembered that that was like those episodes. You know at the beginning of the season, it felt like one thing we did a lot was somehow we pulled out someone from the main cast and there was somebody somewhere else and that was Stanford for that season. Yes.
我被认出来了。是啊，完全是。我刚刚想起来，那些剧集就是这样。你知道在第一季刚开始的时候，我们经常做的一件事就是，不知怎么地，我们会把主要演员里的某个人抽调出去，让他去另一个地方，而那一季斯坦福就是这个地方。是的。
And it was one of those ones where I really liked the Stanford episodes. I think sometimes when we did that, it worked really well. Sometimes when we pulled them out, we were like, oh, just come back. We just like watch you back in the main cast. But that was a time where I felt like it worked pretty well. And I remember thinking because I was like at the beginning, I was like, what was Ed and John doing? And I was like, oh, they weren't there.
这就是其中之一，我真的很喜欢斯坦福的那些戏。我觉得有时候我们这么做时，效果非常好。但有时候把他们调走，我们会想：“哦，快回来吧，我们还是想看你们回到主演员阵容里。”但那一次，我觉得效果挺不错的。我还记得当时我在想——因为一开始我在想，埃德和约翰在干嘛？然后我想：“哦，他们不在。”
So it was fun to just, I forgot about that whole thing. And I remember what I really liked about Stanford was like that was a really funny group of people there. Even the people that didn't have big parts like in the Stanford branch, I just thought we nailed those prototypes or whatever. I was never bored when I had to go over there. No, it was so well done. We talked a little bit about having over on the Scranton set, like Angela and I having
所以看到那一整段感觉挺有意思的，我差点把这事忘了。我记得我真的很喜欢斯坦福的原因是，那里有一群非常搞笑的人。甚至那些在斯坦福分公司没有太多戏份的演员，我也觉得我们完美抓住了那些人物原型什么的。我每次去那边拍戏都一点不觉得无聊。不，真的拍得太棒了。我们之前聊过一点，就是在斯克兰顿的片场，我和安吉拉会有——
a little bit of like FOMO and jealousy of how much fun they were having over on Stanford because everybody was so funny. And also they would only have to work like one and a half days a week. That's right. Super relaxed and just like having the best time and then they got four days off. And we were, we were just like, hey, I forgot about that. Well, well, Jenna, the best example of that was the Michael Scott paper company, which was like, which was like, to me, the one of my favorite arcs we've ever done.
一种FOMO（错失恐惧症）和嫉妒心理，嫉妒他们在斯坦福那边拍得那么开心，因为每个人都太搞笑了。而且他们每周只需要工作大概一天半。没错。超级轻松，过得那叫一个开心，然后他们还能连休四天。而我们——我们当时就想：嘿，我都把这事给忘了。好吧，好吧，珍娜，最好的例子就是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，那对我来说——
And I don't think I wrote any of the episodes for you guys there, but like it has, I think that pairing of people, that group of people on their mission was like one of the times where I was like, wow, this is just like equally, if not more funny than like anything that's going, wait, and that's what Idris Elba was. Was that? Yeah. I guess if you cut back to Idris Elba, you're doing fine. Yeah.
那是我最喜欢的我们拍过的故事线之一。而且我觉得我好像没有为你们写过那里的任何一集，但我觉得那种人物搭配、那群人为了目标而奋斗的组合，绝对是让我觉得“哇，这简直跟——甚至比其他任何剧情都还要搞笑”的时刻等等，那是伊德瑞斯·エル巴加入的时候吗？是吗？是的。我想如果你切到伊德瑞斯·エル巴的镜头，那肯定没问题。是啊。
I loved being in Michael Scott paper company. Oh my God. I kind of didn't want that arc to end. And Vikram, the four of you together. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Amazing. It was so, it was like, it could have been its own movie.
我超喜欢在迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的戏份。哦，天哪。我其实有点舍不得那条故事线结束。还有维克拉姆，你们四个人在一起。哦，天哪。是的。太棒了。那感觉——它简直可以拍成一部独立的电影了。
Like, I know we're not talking about the Michael Scott paper company right now. We're talking about Diwali, but it felt like it was his own bad news bears type movie. But you're, you're right, Mindy, there were these pairings that would happen that were just as pure and beautiful as what was happening in Scranton. And, you know, I got the DVD box set and I watched the deleted scenes. And there's so many scenes at Stanford that never made it in. And like, there's the, the, the character that's like always, like was always breastfeeding. Oh yeah.
我知道我们现在不是在聊迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。我们在聊排灯节，但那感觉就像是一部属于他们自己的类似《少棒闯天下》的电影。不过你说得对，敏迪，有些人物组合的出现，其纯粹和精彩程度丝毫不亚于发生在斯克兰顿的故事。而且，你知道的，我买了DVD套装，还看了删减片段。斯坦福有很多从未在正片中出现的场景。比如说，那个角色——总是——一直在母乳喂养。哦，对。
Make Hannah. Yes. Hannah would make Jim really uncomfortable. And then as far as this episode, I do have a question for you because I was texting with Rashida and she was like, this is the episode. I was so worried everyone was going to hate me because Jim and Karen have this sloppy make out out in the parking lot. Yeah.
扮演汉娜的演员。是的。汉娜会让吉姆感到非常尴尬。至于这一集，我确实有个问题想问你，因为我跟拉希达发短信时，她说：“就是这一集，我当时超级担心所有人都会讨厌我，因为吉姆和卡伦在停车场来了个极其糟糕的舌吻。”是的。
Like a tipsy make out. It's not in the deleted scenes. It didn't even make that cut. And so. It was in the shooting draft. Oh yeah? Did Rashida, did you guys end up shooting that? Cause I was going to ask about that too.
就像是喝了点酒之后的舌吻。这在删减片段里都没有。它甚至都没能进入最终的剪辑。所以——它本来在拍摄剧本里。哦是吗？拉希达，你们最后真的拍了吗？因为我也正想问这个。
When I was going, I have the shooting draft from this episode and I went back and I read it and I was like, wait, wait, Jim and Karen kiss? Yeah. They're kidding you. I said, why are they making out? But then it's nowhere in the episode and it's not in the deleted scenes. Well, I have a mind memory, even though I was the writer on set, obviously for the episode, I have like zero memory of that.
当时我正看着——我手里有这一集的拍摄剧本，我翻出来读了一遍，然后心想：等等，等等，吉姆和卡伦接吻了？是的。他们在开玩笑。我说：“他们俩怎么在舌吻？”但随后这一幕在正片里完全找不到，删减片段里也没有。好吧，我脑子里有记忆，尽管我当时显然是这一集的现场编剧，但我对那段戏的记忆几乎为零。
But I will say that one thing that we used to do, I felt a lot was to write scripts that advance story. And then what we noticed when we only had 21 and a half minutes to air an episode that such like a little one, such a long way, like if there is an attractive woman who is working in the new environment and she seems to have some kind of rapport with Jim or together they're making fun of Andy, you're like, oh, that's interesting, like that might be something. And so it felt like we were always like pulling back that stuff. Like, Jenna, don't you feel like you shot a lot of stuff with, with John?
不过我要说的是，我觉得我们以前经常做的一件事，就是编写推动剧情发展的剧本。然后我们发现，当我们一集只有21分半钟的播出时间时，像这样一个微小的细节却能产生巨大的影响——比如，如果有一个迷人的女性在新环境中工作，而且她似乎跟吉姆很谈得来，或者他们俩在一起取笑安吉拉，你就会觉得：“哦，这挺有意思的，这或许能发展点什么。”所以感觉我们总是会在剪辑时把这些内容删掉一点。珍娜，你不觉得你和约翰拍了很多这样的戏吗？
That was like, not like, cause you guys weren't super, like super flirty in those early seasons, like overtly flirty, but like that you'd watch it and you're like, oh, this was like, they used like less than I thought they would in terms of like showing your guys is like budding romance. Yes. And I would also add that there were some scenes where we would get in, I don't know if I would call it fights, but there were some like disagreements in certain episodes and they would pull back on those two and they, they would make them smaller.
就好像——虽然你们在头几季里并不是那种超级、超级调情的，不是那种公开的调情，但你看的时候会觉得：“哦，这就像是——”他们在展现你们俩萌芽中的浪漫时，用的镜头比我想象的要少。是的。我还要补充一点，有些场景我们甚至会产生——我不知道这算不算争吵，但在某些剧集里确实会有一些分歧，而他们也会把这些场景删减，把它们做得更短。
I wonder if it's, it's, it's interesting, it's just like for so much of the show in terms of romance, it was always like less is more, whereas for comedy, it was like, let's hoist up Tony Gardner onto the table. Like, yeah, like, but for all that stuff, it was, um, yeah, just a little goes a long way. But, um, The relationships were so finessed. I thought they were so smartly done.
我觉得这挺有意思的，在整部剧的浪漫戏份方面，往往是“少即是多”；而对于喜剧效果来说，则是“把托尼·加德纳抬到桌子上去”那种感觉。但对于所有这些情感戏，嗯，点到为止就足够了。不过，嗯，
One of the things I remember really well about this episode was again, like it's such a time capsule of like 2006 or whatever, because the love interest, he wasn't really love interest, but there was an Indian character who my parents preferred to Ryan, that was like a very small part of it. And it was played by this writer, Vali Chandrasekharan, who was kind of a friend of the writers on the show, but not an actor, just a guy, like a guy we knew. There was a real sort of casualness to our show of like, we're just kind of putting it together.
这些人物关系处理得非常巧妙。我觉得它们做得太聪明了。我关于这一集记忆犹新的一件事是，它同样具有2006年前后的强烈时代烙印，因为那个追求者——虽然他算不上真正的追求者，但剧中有一个印度角色，我的父母比瑞恩更喜欢他——这只是其中的一小部分。这个角色由作家瓦利·钱德拉塞卡兰（Vali Chandrasekharan）饰演，他是剧组编剧的朋友，但不是演员，只是个普通人，一个我们认识的熟人。我们的剧有一种很随意的风格，就像是——我们只是把这些元素拼凑在一起。
Yeah. We probably shot this, this is season three, right, for Diwali. It was, we knew that season two had done well. I don't, we'd been nominated probably at this point when we were shooting. We'd been nominated, but we didn't know. So I felt like now, I felt like at the beginning of season three, when we started shooting, we started feeling like a little bit more like, okay, we're not going to just get canceled or something because I remember so much stress earlier on thinking like, it's hard to enjoy
是的。我们大概是这个时候拍的，这是第三季，对吧，拍排灯节这一集的时候。我们当时知道第二季反响很好。我不确定——我们拍摄时可能已经获得提名了。我们当时已经获得了提名，但我们并不知道。所以我觉得，到了第三季刚开始拍摄时，我们开始觉得稍微安心了一点，觉得“好吧，我们大概不会直接被砍掉之类的”，因为我记得早期时承受了太多的压力，觉得：
a show as much when you're like, is this even going to last? And I do remember being able to enjoy things a little bit more starting like at the beginning of a season three. Sorry, I just keep going off of, because I don't get to talk about the office that much. I just, I'm talking really like, like holistically about the show instead of just about this episode. But don't worry, we're going to break down this whole episode and like, get into the
当你整天担心“这节目到底能不能撑下去”时，你真的很难那么享受一部剧。我确实记得从第三季开始，我就能稍微多享受一点拍戏的过程了。抱歉，我一直在跑题，因为我没有太多机会聊《办公室》。我只是在非常——非常全面地谈论这部剧，而不仅仅是局限于这一集。不过别担心，我们会剖析这一整集，然后深入——
nitty gritty of it. Okay. So this can be your office memories. There's no prescription for what we talk about. Yeah. Okay, cool. Greg was on to talk about booze cruise and we just, we went everywhere, you know, but that's, it's such a special chapter in all of our lives.
探讨它的细节。好吧，所以这可以算是你的《办公室》回忆录。我们聊到哪儿算哪儿，没有什么清规戒律。是的，好吧，酷。格雷格来聊过“酒水游轮”那一集，我们当时也是天南海北到处聊，你知道的，但那是我们所有人生活中非常特殊的一段篇章。
I think it's hard to compartmentalize it to one episode. That's such a big part of us. You know, one of the things I remember a lot about doing the office was we didn't realize as writers, how rare it was for Greg to just say, okay, well, I'm just going to give one person from the writer's world on set and that's just going to be the writer of the episode. Some people do that now, but it's usually like an upper level writer. So it's your job to make sure that the intention of Alliance is being corrected, give alts,
我觉得很难把它仅仅归纳为某一集。那是我们人生中很大的一部分。你知道的，关于拍摄《办公室》，我记忆很深的一件事是：我们作为编剧当时并没有意识到，格雷格允许片场只派一位来自编剧团队的代表，而这个人就是该集的编剧，这是一件多么罕见的事。现在有些人也会这么做，但通常派的都是高级别的编剧。所以你的工作是确保台词的意图被正确理解、提供备选台词、
answer questions from the actors. And I was a story editor when I did this. And I remember like, that was pretty stressful, I think. Like I remember being on the set because Miguel Arteta was not one of our directors that we had all the time. And so I remember feeling like, is this like, am I being too, like on set because we're on location a lot for this episode. I was like, am I too much in his hair?
回答演员的问题。我拍这一集时还是一名故事编辑。我记得这其实挺让人有压力的。我记得当时在片场，因为米格尔·阿尔特塔（Miguel Arteta）并不是我们常驻的导演之一。所以我记得当时心里一直在犯嘀咕：我是不是——我是不是太爱在片场晃悠了？因为这一集我们有很多外景。我在想：我是不是太烦人了？
Is he going to yell at me? Because I think season one, I was never alone for hot girl. Like I think Howard and Greg were there for almost all the shooting because it was a lot. I think one of the last ones we shot. But for this one, it was just like, go manage set, answer all Indian questions and make sure it's hilarious and do all alts. It's so funny you say that, Mindy, because my impression of you as the writer on set was just always that you were one of my favorites.
他会不会对大喊大叫？因为我觉得第一季拍《辣妹》时，我从来没独自待过——我觉得霍华德和格雷格几乎参与了所有的拍摄，因为工作量太大了。我觉得那是我们拍的最后一集里的一集。但对于这一集，情况就变成了：去管理片场、回答所有关于印度文化的问题、确保内容极其搞笑，还要负责所有的备选台词。敏迪，你这么说太有趣了，因为我对你作为现场编剧的印象一直都是：你是我最喜欢的编剧之一。
Really? That's so nice. Oh yes. Mostly because you were so up to laugh. Like you found, I always felt like you found everyone hilarious. Oh my God. You seemed to like everything. You had the best alts, so you would sort of throw out ideas maybe based on something
真的吗？太暖心了。哦，是的。主要是因为你太容易被逗笑了。你发现——我总觉得你觉得每个人都超级搞笑。哦，天哪。你似乎对什么都很满意。你总是能想出最棒的备选台词，所以你可能会根据你
you watched us do. You'd be like, oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. You have to do that again. Do that again. And then what do you think about saying this? And it was like, oh my gosh, it was just like this uplifting, exciting.
看着我们表演的反应，随口抛出一些想法。你会说：“哦，天哪。哦，天哪。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。你们必须再演一次。再演一次。然后，你们觉得这样说怎么样？”那种感觉就像是——哦，天哪，这简直是一种鼓舞人心的、令人兴奋的体验。
That's so nice. Oh, I loved it. I loved it. You talked a lot about that and Jen's lotto was very similar as well. Well, Jen, you couldn't get, she just would laugh the whole time. Like we'd actually have to throw her off because she would ruin takes, but yeah. Yeah. I thought, you know, there's this thing that we would do on the show where when a cut would
太暖心了。哦，我太喜欢了。我超爱。你经常聊到这个，珍娜的经历其实也很相似。好吧，珍娜那组简直了，她会笑个不停。我们甚至不得不打断她，因为她会毁掉镜头，但是——是的。我觉得，你知道的，剧组里有这样一件事，每当剪辑版——
come out, the director's cut, and I've never seen it on any other show, we would all gather and watch it together in the writer's room. And director's cuts famously in other shows like make you want to kill yourself. They're usually so bad, but the quality was so good because the cast was so good. And so I remember it was like my favorite time. We could interrupt all of our work and just go into the little living room area of our writer's room and watch. I mean, I was such a fan of the show.
导演剪辑版出来时——我在其他任何剧组都没见过这种事——我们大家会齐聚一堂，在编剧室里一起观看。众所周知，其他剧集的导演剪辑版通常会烂到让人想自杀。它们通常都很糟糕，但我们的质量之所以那么高，是因为演员阵容太棒了。所以我记得那是我的最爱时光。我们可以暂停所有工作，走进编剧室的小客厅区域一起观看。我是说，我真的是这部剧的超级粉丝。
I watched almost every cut of every episode and then I would watch it live too. Like I, and I didn't realize how unusual that is for somebody who works on a show. Most people do it and then they, a lot of actors don't even watch it when it airs. But I, I really was such a huge fan of the show. And a lot of times in those conference room scenes, like I'd have like no lines or one line or something in these four page scenes. And to me, it was like going to second city and just watching everyone just be so funny and it just be for free.
我几乎看过了每一集的每一个剪辑版，然后播出时我还会看直播。而且我以前并没有意识到，对于一个剧组成员来说，这有多么不寻常。大多数人拍完就完事了，很多演员甚至在剧集播出时都不看。但我——我真的是这部剧的超级大粉丝。很多时候在那些会议室的场景里，面对那些长达四页的戏份，我可能一句台词都没有，或者只有一句台词。对initializeApp我来说，这就好像去了“第二城”喜剧剧团（Second City），免费看着每个人都那么搞笑。
And you'd be in this like freezing cold room and there'd be snacks every two hours. And I was like, how could this be better? I felt like such an abundance of riches. I just loved sitting and watching everyone in character, just reacting. Yeah. Mindy, I remember one time you were on stage and BJ and you guys were at reception by Jenna and you guys were talking and I walked up and you were having a conversation about some type of like economics.
而且你坐在那种冰冷刺骨的房间里，每隔两个小时就有零食供应。当时我想：怎么可能会有比这更好的事？我感觉自己拥有数之不尽的财富。我就是喜欢坐在那里，看着每个人都沉浸在角色中，做出各种即兴反应。是的。敏迪，我记得有一次你站在舞台上，BJ和你们俩在珍娜身后的前台区域，你们在聊天，然后我走了过去，听到你们正在讨论某种——某种经济学话题。
It was like some kind of like you'd, you'd expanded economics and I walked up and I was like, I'm going to go over here. I was just like, they are two of the smartest people I have ever met. And I'm going to hard pivot and back away. Wait, BJ and I were talking about economics. We weren't fighting. I'm so surprised. Oh no, you were, it was a heated discussion.
那就像是某种——你们探讨了某种经济学理论，我走过去听了听，心想：“我要去那边了。”我当时的感觉就是：他们俩是我见过最聪明的人。我要立刻一百八十度大转弯，悄悄退下。等等，BJ和我当时在讨论经济学？我们没吵架吧？我太惊讶了。哦不，你们当时在激烈讨论。
Oh, it was a heated discussion. You were on opposite sides. That is so funny. 100%. Well, I just, I remember you and Paul and BJ as a little trio, probably because you were the writers who were with the actors. So between takes, you guys would always kind of huddle up and talk like story ideas and like what's happening in the writer's room.
哦，那是一场激烈的讨论。你们站在对立的立场上。太搞笑了。百分之百。好吧，我只记得你、保罗和BJ就像是个三人小团体，可能是因为你们是跟演员们待在一起的编剧。所以在拍摄间隙，你们总是会聚在一起，讨论故事创意以及编剧室里正在发生的事情。
And so you were having to kind of manage two jobs at once. And I used to like hover around you guys and eavesdrop and just like hope you would invite me in to your hilarious convert. Yes. Some of my favorite memories are listening to you guys discuss story and character and pitch jokes to each other in between scenes. Well, that's so funny because I felt like when we were in the annex, we, you know, we were, the writers were in the annex.
所以你们当时得同时应付两份工作。我以前总是喜欢在你们周围转悠、偷听，希望能被邀请加入你们那场搞笑的对话。是的。我最美好的回忆之一，就是在镜头之外听你们讨论故事和人物、互相抛梗。好吧，太搞笑了，因为我觉得当我们待在角落办公室时——你知道的，编剧们都在角落办公室里。
I'm sure you're sure you guys have talked about this many times, but we were in the annex obviously because then we could go be the writer's room and we wouldn't have to be in some of the big group scenes. But I remember also thinking like, but I want to be in the big group scenes. Like I, like those were the funnest scenes to watch when like, you know, Dwight would run in and be like, everyone to the roof. Like I, we just were left out of those scenes like about Diwali. So here's a couple of things that I felt were maybe interesting to say, which was that we
我确信你们一定已经讨论过很多次了，我们待在角落办公室显然是为了能当好编剧室，这样就不用参与某些大型群戏了。但我也记得当时自己心里在想：我也想参与大型群戏！那些——那些才是最好看的戏，比如说迪怀特冲进来喊道：“所有人上屋顶！”我们当时被排除在那些关于排灯节的大场面之外。所以，以下是我觉得有些意思、值得一说的事情，那就是我们
only cast my parents in it, which seems just like a complete act of nepotism and favoritism because we had auditioned the parts and Greg had felt that the actors we had found of that age group, like the late fifties, early sixties were like a little bit too either theatrical for that style of acting on our show or too stilted because they had no acting experience. Now I'm the first to say that my parents acting was also very stilted, but he was like, at least they bear some familial resemblance to you. So we'll just like, we'll just like put them in there. And I don't know if you guys remember this, but I remember going into it.
只让我的父母在里面客串了，这看起来完全就是裙带关系和偏心，因为我们之前为这些角色试镜过，而格雷格觉得我们找到的那个年龄段的演员——大概五十多岁、六十岁出头——要么对于我们剧的表演风格来说显得有点太戏剧化了，要么因为毫无表演经验而显得太僵硬。现在我是第一个承认我父母的演技其实也非常僵硬的人，但他觉得：至少他们跟你长得有点家族相似度，所以我们就把他们塞进去吧。我不知道你们还记不记得，但我记得当时在开拍前，
My mom was like, had this energy of like, I'm just like going to be so much better than, than your father. Like I just know, like neither of them did any acting. She was, she was a doctor. He was an architect. She had the sense like coming over that she's like, I just hope that you give me the most lines cause I'm just naturally better on camera and like it's going to be good. But then Miguel like fell in love with my dad.
我妈妈身上散发出的那种气场是：“我绝对要比你爸演得好得多。我就是知道——”他们俩其实都没有任何表演经验。我妈是个医生，我爸是个建筑师。她当时有一种心态，觉得：“我只希望你能给我安排最多的台词，因为我在镜头前天生就表现得更好，这绝对会效果拔群。”但随后米格尔却爱上了我爸爸。
Like he was like, we have to give him more lines. Like he's killing it. And you guys remember like this is the show where if anyone ever fell for anyone, Troy underbridge, who was like just kind of like a, if anyone was interesting to a director in the wrong reasons, like just cause like, oh my God, like I just love that guy's look, they could recur on the show for a long time. And I remember being like, I cannot have my dad and my mom come back here like ever again to do this kind of thing.
他当时就说：“我们必须给他加更多台词，他太惊艳了。”你们还记得吗——这就是那种剧组，如果导演对任何人产生了好感——比如特洛伊·昂德布里奇（Troy Underbridge），或者任何因为错误原因吸引了导演注意的人——仅仅是因为“哦天哪，我太喜欢那家伙的长相了”，他们就能在剧里长期客串下去。而我当时的心态是：我绝对不能让我爸妈再来这儿——再来干这种事了。
So I remember Miguel Arteta was like, Hey, do you think we can add your dad to the background of like another scene? And I was like, no, we can't. I was going to ask you what it was like for you to have them on set. Uh, I was, I don't know if you guys feel this way. Well, you don't really, because like your family, you guys are so tight. So I don't think you have this, but I did not feel so established on the show as a writer or as actor that I felt so comfortable having them there.
所以我记得米格尔·阿尔特塔当时问：“嘿，你觉得我们能让你爸爸去另一个场景里当个背景板吗？”而我的回答是：“不，绝对不行。”我本来想问你，让他们俩去片场客串对你来说是什么感觉？呃，我不知道你们会不会有这种感觉。好吧，你们大概不会，因为你们的家庭关系非常紧密。所以你们可能没有这种体会，但我当时并没有觉得自己作为编剧或演员在剧里已经稳居脚跟，以至于能那么坦然地让他们俩也出现在片场。
Like I was really worried about it, um, seeming unprofessional or just like that they would tell boring stories to people and like Jenna would be like, Hey, can you get this guy away for me? Tell like an AD, like I can't hear, I can't hear the story anymore. Like, can you please? So I think I was worried and I think I told them like, don't like talk to people at craft services for too long. Like just say hi and answer questions, but don't like launch into, um, you know, other
我真的很担心这会显得不够专业，或者担心他们会跟别人讲一些无聊的故事，然后珍娜可能会对助理导演说：“嘿，你能把这家伙从我身边弄走吗？别让他再讲故事了——我真的听不下去了，能让他走开吗？”所以我想我当时很焦虑，我甚至叮嘱他们俩：别在剧组餐饮区跟别人聊太久。打个招呼、回答完问题就行了，千万别滔滔不绝地讲起——
stuff. But that was one thing. I thought they were delightful. We were so excited to have them and they were so cute, Mindy. They were so cute. Well, they're both like five foot four. They're just like both like little, they're both little people. Yeah, they're my people.
其他乱七八糟的事。但这确实是一段独特的经历。我觉得他们俩太招人喜欢了。我们当时能让他们客串都兴奋坏了，而且他们真的太可爱了，敏迪。他们俩简直萌化了。好吧，他们俩身高都只有五英尺四英寸。他们俩就像是——两个小不点。是的，他们就是我的人。
I, I remember your mom complimented my blouse and I remember it. It's nice. She liked the color on me and I was like, Oh, thanks so much. I don't know. I thought they were delightful. And by the way, I thought their acting was amazing. Thank you. I was watching them in that scene with Steve and I was like, they are killing it.
我、我记得你妈妈称赞了我的衬衫，我还记得。挺好的。她喜欢这个颜色穿在我身上的效果，当时我说，哦，非常感谢。我不知道。我觉得他们太可爱了。顺便说一句，我觉得他们的演技太棒了。谢谢。我看他们在和史蒂夫演的那场戏时，心想，他们演得太绝了。
Oh my gosh. Your mom ate him up. Like that was amazing. They were, I mean, I cannot believe because I was at the time where I was like, uh, I'd like to have a scene with Steve, you know, like it felt so special and here they are. Like he's at a crossroads with Carol and my dad is like, you should be with her. I don't forget exactly what he said, but I remember being like, this is kind of a juicy scene.
哦，天哪。你妈妈把他的风头全抢了。简直太棒了。他们，我是说，我简直不敢相信，因为当时我的感觉是，呃，我很想跟史蒂夫有一场对手戏，你知道吗，那种感觉太特别了，而他们居然拍了。就像他和卡洛尔走到了十字路口，我爸爸就说，你应该和她在一起。我不记得他具体说了什么，但我记得当时的感觉是，这真是一场有看头的戏。
But you know, there's a nice little story because like, I feel like Pam's stories had such an emotional impact, but they often didn't have like lots and lots of like lines to them, but they always were so impactful as like, I thought your little story in this one was pretty sweet, Jenna. Like it was like, you know, you didn't really want to go and then you end up having like, I don't know, I thought it was like a nice, I liked those kinds of Pam stories. I liked it too. I also, I was really struck by how incredibly good looking David Denman was in this episode.
但你知道，这有个挺有意思的小故事，因为我觉得帕姆的故事具有很强的感染力，但它们通常没有很多很多的台词，不过它们总是那么有感染力，比如，我觉得你在这一集里的小故事挺温馨的，珍娜。就像是，你知道的，你本来真的不想去，结果最后却，我不知道，我觉得这挺不错的，我挺喜欢那种帕姆的故事的。我也挺喜欢的。还有，大卫·丹曼在这个造型里帅得惊人，这让我印象非常深刻。
I was like, Pam, Pam, stop for a second, open your eyes, see what's in front of you. And just maybe, I mean, maybe just revisit that for one night, Pam. It's one night. That's what, that's what I was thinking the whole time. Yeah. David Denman. He was really tan. He was really, like, I don't know what David was doing in his real life, but he's super
我当时就想，帕姆，帕姆，停一下，睁大眼睛，看看你面前的人。也许，我是说，也许就为了那一晚重新考虑一下吧，帕姆。就一个晚上。那就是我当时脑子里一直想的事情。是的。大卫·丹曼。他晒得真黑。他真的，我不知道大卫在现实生活中在做什么，但他超级
tan. Yeah. In his shape. He was good to show that Roy had good qualities and was good looking too, so that you weren't just like, what the hell? Like why, why is it not? It's good that he was, yeah, David Denman is a legitimate smoke show. He doesn't get enough credit.
黑。是的。身材很好。这很好地证明了罗伊也有优点，长得也很帅，这样你才不会觉得，搞什么鬼？为什么，为什么不是他？他这样挺好的，是的，大卫·丹曼绝对是个极品大帅哥。他受到的赞誉还不够多。
Yeah. Guys, this was so much fun. Now that I've done it and you guys made me feel so welcome, I would love to come back and do another one sometime. We will have you back any time, Mindy. I really, I'm sure you already did this and talked about it with somebody else on the show, but if we ever do branch wars, Jenna, I have so many funny memories of it. Like one thing I remember really well was normally you'd sit in a conference room type
是的。伙计们，这太有趣了。既然我已经体验过了，而且你们让我感到宾至如归，我真希望能有机会再来客串一集。我们随时欢迎你回来，敏迪。我真的，我确信你已经做过这个节目，并且和剧里的其他人聊过了，但如果我们以后做“分公司大战”的话，珍娜，我有很多有趣的回忆。比如我印象最深的一件事是，通常你会坐在会议室类型的
scene and Michael would be the person that would just be so funny that you felt like I'm going to break and die. And I remember I was not, I was on set with you because I'd written the episode, but I was not obviously at the branch as a character, I wasn't there. And I remember when you had to take over for Michael because he was, had like a breakdown, that was like some of the funniest moments of any episode I'd ever seen. Like you in front of like just eating it and having to be like this valiant assistant and friend to Michael.
场景里，迈克尔总是那个搞笑到让你觉得你要笑场笑死的人。我记得我不在，我和你在片场，因为我写了这一集，但显然我不是以角色的身份在分公司，我当时不在那里。我记得当迈克尔因为情绪崩溃，你不得不接替他的时候，那是我见过的任何一集里最搞笑的时刻之一。就像你站在那儿硬着头皮上，不得不扮演迈克尔英勇的助手和朋友。
I remember that and I also remember Michael cutting a piece of her sweater off. Those were my two favorite moments of that episode. Thank you, Mindy. I had a great time. Mindy. Thank you so much. It was such a joy to see you. Thank you so much.
我记得那个，我还记得迈克尔剪掉了她毛衣的一截。那是我对那一集最喜欢的两个瞬间。谢谢你，敏迪。我玩得很开心。敏迪。非常感谢你。见到你真是太高兴了。非常感谢你。
It was really fun. Great to see you. And yeah, guys, good. I mean, I was going to say good luck, but you don't need good luck. You're already, this is the number one podcast ever, but. Oh, stop it. By the way, speaking of, I can't believe legally, well, I'm three, I'm so excited. Thank you.
真的很有趣。很高兴见到你。还有，伙计们，祝你们。我是说我本想说祝你好运，但你们不需要好运。你们已经是，这是史上排名第一的播客了，不过。哦，别说了。顺便说一句，说到这个，法律上我简直不敢相信，好吧，我三岁了，我太兴奋了。谢谢。
We love you so much, Mindy. Okay. Bye. Do not forget to like. We are back. Mindy Kaling. So fun. Please come back.
我们太爱你啦，敏迪。好的。再见。别忘了点赞。我们回来啦。敏迪·卡灵。太有趣了。请再来哦。
That was so great. We have to have her back. I know. All right. Lady, should we break down this episode? We talked a little bit about this cold open with Mindy. We open in the office. Kelly is helping Ryan with his curta and Michael enters
真是太棒了。我们必须请她再来。我懂的。好了。女士们，我们要剖析这一集吗？我们刚才和敏迪简单聊了一下这个开场白。我们在办公室开始。凯莉正在帮瑞恩弄他的古尔塔（男士长上衣），然后迈克尔进来了
and he starts laughing at it. He calls it a dress, right? But then Pam and Kelly gush about how handsome Ryan looks and Michael suddenly wishes that he had one too. He's such a child. He's like, how come you didn't get me one? I think you can see Mindy starting to break when he says that.
他开始嘲笑这身衣服。他管这叫裙子，对吧？但接着帕姆和凯莉对瑞恩看起来有多帅赞不绝口，迈克尔突然也希望自己能有一件。他就像个小孩子一样。他说，你怎么不给我买一件？当他说这话时，你可以看到敏迪开始笑场了。
And I wondered if that was an improvised line, Jenna. No, it's in the script. Because I feel like you can see Mindy starting to do that break that she does. Like she was taken by surprise? Yeah, yeah. No, that's just Mindy breaking because you said words, which is what Mindy used to like to do.
我在想那是不是即兴台词，珍娜。不，剧本里就是这么写的。因为我觉得你能看到敏迪开始出现她那种标志性的笑场。就像她被突袭了一样？对，对。不，那只是敏迪因为你说了台词而笑场，敏迪以前就喜欢这样。
Well, now we have a party planning committee scene. You guys, we lived for these. We got so tickled whenever there was one in a script. I find it fascinating that in this party planning committee scene, it is Ryan, Meredith, Pam, Angela and Phyllis, and they are discussing who's gonna carpool with who. There's a chart. Clearly they couldn't plan this party.
好了，现在我们迎来了活动筹划委员会的场景。伙计们，我们太爱看这些了。每当剧本里有这个环节时，我们就会觉得特别开心。我觉得很有意思的是，在这个活动筹划委员会的场景里，有瑞恩、梅雷迪思、帕姆、安吉拉和菲利斯，他们在讨论谁和谁拼车。有个图表。显然他们没法策划这个派对。
They were invited guests. So they had to have something to plan. So they're planning carpools. This is what Phyllis wrote on the dry erase board. And Bob's Yukon, and she was very proud to say that he had a Yukon. And Bob's Yukon would be Phyllis, Stanley, Angela, Kevin, and Pam.
他们是被邀请的客人。所以他们必须得找点事情来策划。于是他们在策划拼车。这是菲利斯写在白板上的内容。鲍勃的育空车（Yukon），她非常自豪地宣布他有一辆育空车。而坐鲍勃育空车的人将是菲利斯、斯坦利、安吉拉、凯文和帕姆。
And Meredith's minivan would be Meredith, Darryl, Lonnie, Creed, Ryan, and Kelly. Now, who is missing from the carpool? Oscar, he's on leave. Michael and Dwight. Who's riding with Michael and Dwight? They're on their own, I guess. Yeah, good question.
梅雷迪思的小型货车将坐梅雷迪思、达里尔、朗尼、克里德、瑞恩和凯莉。那么，拼车名单里漏掉了谁？奥斯卡，他请假了。迈克尔和德怀特。谁和迈克尔、德怀特一起坐车？他们大概是自己走吧。是的，好问题。
Well, I guess Michael and Carol are gonna go together. But how did Dwight get there? He's solo, he's solo. But I want you guys to know there is a fantastic deleted scene. There's an extension of this party planning committee scene. And it's so funny because Angela doesn't want anyone to go. And I actually have a talking head
好吧，我猜迈克尔和卡洛尔会一起去。但德怀特是怎么去的？他是独行侠，他是独行侠。但我想让你们知道，有一个超棒的被删减片段。活动筹划委员会的场景里有一个加长部分。非常搞笑，因为安吉拉不想让任何人去。我其实有一个独白镜头
where it sort of sets up why I'm so against Diwali. And it's not really about Diwali. It's because I think Dwight might still have a thing for Kelly or maybe there'll be someone else there he might be interested in. So I really have this attitude that, listen, I actually have this line where I say, certain people in this office are a little too obsessed
大致解释了我为什么这么反对排灯节。其实这并不是针对排灯节本身。而是因为我觉得德怀特可能对凯莉还念念不忘，或者也许那里会有其他人能引起他的兴趣。所以我真的有这样一种态度，听着，我甚至有这样一句台词，我说办公室里的某些人有点太迷恋
with things from India. Yes. So she's jealous. And that's really her filter through all of this. That's why she's so salty all the way through. And then Jenna, what I love is she's trying to like talk people out of going. And Ryan was like, well, Kelly's kind of into it.
来自印度的东西了。没错。所以她在吃醋。这其实是她贯穿这一切的心理滤镜。这就是为什么她从头到尾都表现得这么阴阳怪气。然后珍娜，我喜欢的是她试图劝大家别去。而瑞恩说，嗯，凯莉挺感兴趣的。
I thought we could go. And then he's like, I don't care. Actually, we can bail. I don't care. Ryan was like, you guys want me to bail? Fine. We actually got a lot of mail wondering why Angela was so salty about this festival.
我觉得我们可以去。然后他又说，我不在乎。其实我们可以放鸽子。我不在乎。瑞恩当时的意思是，你们想让我放鸽子？行啊。我们确实收到了很多信件，想知道为什么安吉拉对这个节日这么阴阳怪气。
And so I'm really glad you shared that deleted scene because there was this whole extra storyline element that it's you and I think you kind of see it a little bit in the scene where Pam is telling Kelly, she might not go and this and that, and your head has popped up behind that partition. And you are a little jealous when Dwight with such authority says he's single.
所以我很高兴你分享了这个被删减的片段，因为这里面有一条额外的剧情线，那就是你，而且我觉得你在帕姆告诉凯莉她可能不会去之类的那场戏里也能看出一点端倪，你的头从那个隔断后面探了出来。当德怀特信誓旦旦地说自己单身时，你确实有点吃醋。
He's not seeing anyone. Yes. Because Kelly suggests maybe Pam go with Dwight if she doesn't want to go alone. And she's like, you're single, right Dwight? And Dwight's like, oh yeah, I'm totally single. And I think you see that little jealousy right there from Angela like, ooh, don't like it.
他没在跟任何人交往。是的。因为凯莉建议如果帕姆不想一个人去的话，可以和德怀特一起去。然后她说，你单身对吧，德怀特？德怀特就说，哦对，我完全单身。我想你就在那一刻看到了安吉拉的小嫉妒，就像，哦，真看不惯。
There's deleted scenes that really sort of play out this Dwight Angela storyline and her jealousy and how it resolves itself. But that's what was going on for Angela Martin. So Michael gets aware of the fact that people might not be as enthusiastic about this Diwali festival as he would like. He says he thinks it's because people are just ignorant
有些被删减的片段真正展现了德怀特和安吉拉这条故事线，以及她的嫉妒心和它是如何解决的。但这就是安吉拉·马丁当时的心理活动。所以迈克尔意识到大家对这个排灯节的热情可能并不像他希望的那样高涨。他说他觉得这是因为大家对其他文化
about other cultures and he really does not want to be embarrassed by everyone's ignorance in front of his girlfriend Carol. Yeah, so he's got to educate everyone. So this means we're all going in the conference room. Yes. Once again, where does Michael get these posters? It feels last minute, but yet he has all these posters.
无知，他真的不想在女友卡洛尔面前因为大家的无知而感到尴尬。是的，所以他必须给所有人上一课。这意味着我们要一起去会议室了。没错。又来了，迈克尔从哪弄来的这些海报？感觉很临时，但他却有这么多海报。
Does he send Dwight on like a mad dash? There's all kinds of posters once we get in the conference room. It's so true. And when he starts showing us this slideshow, you notice how there's a photo of Michael and Carol kissing. It's so awkward. That accidentally makes its way into this presentation.
难道他派德怀特去疯狂抢购了吗？一进会议室，到处都是各种海报。确实如此。当他开始给我们播放这个幻灯片时，你注意到里面有一张迈克尔和卡洛尔接吻的照片了吗。太尴尬了。这张照片阴差阳错地出现在了幻灯片里。
Yeah. Well, then he passes out the Kamasutra to the employees. And remember, Angela, those were like little booklets that Phil Shea had to put together in print of all these Kamasutra positions and they were blurred out for television, but they were not blurred out in real life. We're all sitting in the room as actors
好吧，然后他把《爱经》（Kamasutra）发给员工。记不记得，安吉拉，那些都是菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）制作并打印的小册子，上面印满了各种《爱经》的姿势，电视播出的画面被打了马赛克，但在现实生活中并没有打马赛克。我们所有演员都坐在房间里
and we get these little booklets. And I remember being totally like, oh, oh, wow. Okay. Of course, Kevin says this is the best meeting they've ever had. The best one. If you guys get a chance and rewatch the scene, at the end, Toby takes away the Kamasutra.
然后我们拿到了这些小册子。我记得当时整个人就是，哦，哦，哇。好吧。当然，凯文说这是他们开过的最好的会议。史上最好的一次。如果大家有机会重看这一幕，在最后，托比收走了《爱经》。
And I want you to look at Phyllis' face because she makes an expression like she's really bummed out to lose the book. Oh my gosh, I missed that. Oh, I can't wait to go back and see that. Well, Angela, should we talk a little bit about what's going on in Stanford? You mean with Josh Porter's like biker shorts
我想让你们看看菲利斯的表情，因为她做出了一个好像因为失去这本书而感到非常沮丧的表情。哦天哪，我错过了这个。哦，我等不及要回去找来看看了。好了，安吉拉，我们要不要聊聊斯坦福那边发生的事？你是说乔什·波特的紧身骑行短裤
and his fancy bike and Jim and his clunky bike with a big basket? What's happening, Jim? What's going on? Well, Jim has started biking to work. Just like Josh, he says, I'm gonna save gas money. It keeps me in shape. He did not anticipate how sweaty he would be.
和他那辆昂贵的自行车，还有吉姆和他那辆带着大篮子的笨重自行车？怎么回事，吉姆？发生什么事了？好吧，吉姆开始骑自行车上班了。就像乔什一样，他说，我要省下油钱。这能保持我的身材。他没有料到自己会出这么多汗。
That talking head is so funny. How much sweat they put on him. Angela, do you remember how they used to make us sweaty when you have to be sweaty? They spray you. Yeah, they would either spray you with like a bottle that you would mist your plants with, or they would spray you with like those Evian mist sprays
那段独白太搞笑了。他们给他弄了多少汗水啊。安吉拉，你还记得以前需要我们出汗的时候，他们是怎么让我们出汗的吗？他们会喷你。对，他们要么用那种给植物喷水的小喷雾瓶喷你，要么就用那种依云面部喷雾
and they have to like spritz you under the arms. But then they'd have to come and do it like between every take because it would dry. But then sometimes they would put like baby oil around like your hairline and then spray you so it would look especially sweaty. Yeah. I've just given everybody a little inside info
往你胳肢窝底下喷。但他们必须在每次拍摄间隙都来补喷，因为汗水会干掉。有时他们会在你发际线周围抹点婴儿油，然后再喷水，这样看起来就会特别出汗。没错。我刚刚向大家透露了一点关于如何让演员出汗的内幕消息。你们可以在家试试。珍娜，我只是觉得你刚才说了好多次出汗这个词。
on how you make an actor sweaty. You can try it at home. Jenna, I'm just laughing at how many times you just said sweaty. Sweaty. All right, so now at four minutes, 23 seconds. Sam, will you play Mustang? Flirty Karen.
出汗。好吧，现在是4分23秒。萨姆，放一下野马。调情的凯伦。
Flirty Karen. That's my mom, Birdie Kinsey. Flirty Karen, Karen says, hey, nice basket. Ever since the whole chips incident, she's smitten. Yep. So then Josh comes over and gives Karen the company credit card because they have to work late and they're allowed to buy dinner.
调情的凯伦。那是我的妈妈，伯蒂·金西。调情的凯伦说，嘿，不错的篮子。自从上次薯片事件后，她就迷上他了。没错。然后乔什走过来给凯伦公司信用卡，因为他们得加班，公司允许他们买晚饭。
But he says, you know, no more than $20 a person this time. This time, $20 a person, we shot this in 2006. Is there a meal out there that you order that's more than $20 a person? Maybe there's a reason Stanford doesn't make it. I mean, my gosh. I don't know. Maybe I just don't eat at very fancy places for my takeout,
但他说，这次每人不超过20美元哦。这次每人20美元，我们是2006年拍的这集。现在还有什么外卖是一顿饭超过20美元的吗？也许斯坦福混不下去是有原因的。我的天呐。我不知道。也许我只是不在那些很高级的地方买外卖，
but I feel like I would be challenged to order a meal for more than $20 a person in 2006. Yeah, especially late at night in Scranton. What are they getting? Like, Thai food. I know. Exactly, this is not difficult. Andy, though, busts out some Jagermeister.
但我觉得要在2006年点一顿超过20美元的外卖还挺有挑战性的。对，特别是深夜在斯克兰顿。他们能点到什么？比如泰餐。我懂的。确实，这根本不难。不过安迪拿出了野格利口酒（Jagermeister）。
He's got other plans. He's ready to party. Ed Helms' face when he holds up that Jagermeister bottle and the shot glasses is hilarious. You get a window into who Andy was in college and you're like, oh, buddy. Well, back in Scranton, things are getting exciting because everyone is showing up to Diwali.
他另有打算。他准备狂欢了。埃德·海尔姆斯举起那瓶野格和烈酒杯时的表情太搞笑了。你能从中窥见安迪在大学时是什么样的人，然后你会想，哦，老兄。好吧，斯克兰顿这边，气氛开始变得热闹起来，因为大家都来参加排灯节了。
They're arriving, they're walking in. It's really, really bright and colorful and there's music playing. And Phyllis is like, isn't it fun to take our shoes off? And Angela's like, I wish not everyone took their shoes off. And Kevin's like, stop it. I told you it was a condition. So you guys remember in grief counseling,
他们陆续抵达，走了进来。现场真的非常明亮、色彩斑斓，还放着音乐。菲利斯说，脱掉鞋子感觉好有趣啊。安吉拉则说，我希望不是每个人都脱鞋。凯文说，别这样。我告诉过你这是个病情。所以大家还记得在哀伤辅导那一集里，
we talked about a deleted scene that would have been in the episode where Angela and Kevin go off again about his sweaty feet. Yes, this is a callback to a deleted scene. So it's gonna go unappreciated by most viewers, but those diehard viewers who watch those deleted scenes will know what this means. I feel like someone in the writer's room
我们聊过一个被删减的片段，本来应该在那一集里出现，讲的是安吉拉和凯文又开始争论他脚爱出汗的事。对，这是对一个被删减片段的呼应。所以大部分观众可能不会注意到，但那些看过被删减片段的铁杆粉丝会知道这是什么意思。我觉得编剧室里的某个人
was really determined to make sure we had scenes about Kevin's feet. I feel like it was a note card on the wall that said Kevin's sweaty feet and someone loved it and kept wanting to get it in the episodes. Well, this is Angela's worst nightmare, people taking off all their shoes, even minus Kevin's sweaty feet.
真的是铁了心要确保我们有关于凯文脚出汗的戏份。我觉得墙上贴了一张便签写着“凯文脚出汗”，有人特别喜欢这个梗，一直想把它塞进剧集里。好吧，这可是安吉拉的噩梦，每个人都脱鞋，甚至还不算凯文那出汗的脚。
I mean, this is just not how she wants to be at a party. No, no. So Angela, we got a fan question about these Diwali scenes. It comes from Sarah Beth Miller. She asked, was this a real Diwali celebration happening in the filming of this episode? How did you get all of those people in those beautiful costumes?
我是说，这根本不是她想参加派对的方式。不，不。所以安吉拉，我们收到了一个关于这些排灯节场景的粉丝提问。来自萨拉·贝丝·米勒（Sarah Beth Miller）。她问，拍摄这一集时真的有一场排灯节庆祝活动吗？你们是怎么把所有这些穿着漂亮服装的人聚在一起的？
Great question, Sarah Beth. I mean, there are so many people in this scene. So here's the thing, it was not a real Diwali festival. That was all put together by our amazing crew, just specifically for this episode. Yes, our set designer, Michael Gallenberg and his team, they decorated that whole gym. Michael had to do a lot of research
问得好，萨拉·贝丝。我是说，这个场景里有那么多的人。事情是这样的，这并不是真正的排灯节。这一切都是我们出色的剧组人员专门为这一集搭建的。是的，我们的布景设计师迈克尔·盖伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）和他的团队装饰了整个体育馆。迈克尔做了大量的研究
in order to transform the gymnasium to feel like a real Diwali festival. So I think he would be very proud to know that you wondered if this was real, like maybe we just stepped into an existing festival. No, they made the whole thing. They did a fantastic job. As far as costumes go,
以便将体育馆改造成真正的排灯节节日现场。所以我想他如果知道你好奇这到底是不是真的，就像我们是不是真的误打误撞走进了一个正在举办的节日一样，他一定会为此感到骄傲。不，整个场地都是他们搭建的。他们做得太棒了。至于服装，
my character did not get to dress up Jenna. I was so bummed, you know? I mean, she actually is just wearing what she wore to work. She didn't even change out of her work clothes. I know. But some of the cast did get to dress up. BJ, Rain, Mindy, and I'm sure our wardrobe stylist was thrilled to do something
我的角色可没有换上盛装，珍娜。我当时好失落，你知道吗？我是说，她其实就穿着上班穿的衣服。她甚至都没换下工作服。我知道。但剧组确实有些演员盛装打扮了。BJ、雷恩、敏迪，我敢肯定我们的服装造型师做梦都想做点
other than just drab office attire. They used to get so excited every time we got to wear anything other than our office attire. And Pam didn't really dress up, but she is not in her office attire, which was fun. I had a whole separate fitting for that.
除了解闷的办公室制服之外的事。每当我们可以穿除办公室制服以外的衣服时，他们总是兴奋得不得了。帕姆虽然没有盛装打扮，但她穿的也不是工作服，这挺有意思的。为此我专门做了一次服装试穿。
We got to see casual Pam. And did you notice I got to wear my hair differently as well? But we did find out some interesting trivia about all the other background actors who were dressed up for this festival. Yes, we went to Kintopedia and he said our casting office worked with Central Casting. Now, Central Casting is a casting agency in Los Angeles.
我们看到了休闲风的帕姆。你们有没有注意到我的发型也变得不一样了？不过我们确实打听到了一些关于为这个节日盛装打扮的其他背景演员的有趣八卦。是的，我们去了金托百科（Kintopedia），他说我们的选角办公室与中央选角公司（Central Casting）进行了合作。现在，中央选角公司是洛杉矶的一家选角机构。
They specialize in sort of the background actors and filling out the picture, right? Yeah. Central Casting reached out to a lot of the Indian community here in Los Angeles to hire those background players. All in all, Kint said we had 100 extras working this episode and every single one of them brought their own very beautiful costuming for us to use.
他们专门负责寻找背景演员并丰富画面的构图，对吧？是的。中央选角公司联系了洛杉矶当地的许多印度裔社群来招聘这些背景演员。总的来说，金托说我们这一集有100名群众演员，他们每个人都自带了非常漂亮的服装供我们使用。
And to kind of fill out the world, Kint also hired a professional dance company to come and lead us in some of the dances. He found a company called NDM Dance Productions and he hired their director choreographer, Dev Mahajan. And Dev hired eight dancers. He choreographed, rehearsed their dance in the morning of that day four of shooting
为了丰富这个场景的世界观，金托还雇佣了一个专业的舞蹈团来带领我们跳一些舞蹈。他找了一家名为NDM Dance Productions的公司，并雇用了他们的导演兼编舞德夫·马哈詹（Dev Mahajan）。德夫雇用了八名舞者。他负责编舞，并在拍摄第四天的早上排练了舞蹈，我们就是在那天拍摄了所有舞蹈镜头。
is when we shot all the dancing. And then we filmed it later in the afternoon and all the dancers were their own costumes as well. I actually went to the website. Of course you did, lady. You went to the dancers website. What'd you find out? They have appeared on tons of shows.
然后我们在下午进行了拍摄，所有的舞者也都穿着他们自己的服装。我其实去过他们的网站。你当然去了，女士。你去了舞者的网站。你发现了什么？他们上过超级多的节目。
So you think you can dance, E live Oscar coverage, Good Morning America, Superstars of Dance and MTV's America's Best Dance Crew. If you wanna look them up, you can find them at ndmdance.com. It was super cool and it really did end up feeling like a real party, like a real celebration. It really did.
比如《舞林争霸》（So You Think You Can Dance）、E!频道的奥斯卡红毯报道、《早安美国》（Good Morning America）、《舞林高手》（Superstars of Dance）和MTV的《全美街舞大赛》（America's Best Dance Crew）。如果你想了解他们，可以在 ndmdance.com 找到他们。这真的太酷了，最后拍出来感觉真像个真正的派对，就像一个真正的庆祝活动。确实如此。
I wish my character wanted to participate more because me, Angela, that is me would have been right out there like just having a great time. So it was always hard in these moments to not get to be in costume and not participate and be kind of the grump on the wall, you know?
我真希望我的角色能更多地参与其中，因为如果换作我，安吉拉，我肯定早就冲出去融入其中，玩得超开心了。所以每到这些时刻，不能穿上戏服，不能参与其中，只能当个靠在墙边的扫兴鬼，其实总是挺难受的，你知道吗？
I do and we'll talk a little bit about my dancing later but I did get to dance a little bit and I was thrilled. Yes. Very fun. All right, so yeah, so there are people that got to dress up, people that didn't. Michael and Carol walk in with a whole different idea of what this party is. Michael has clearly told Carol
我懂的，我们稍后会聊聊我的舞技，我确实跳了一小段舞，我当时兴奋极了。是的。太有趣了。好吧，所以有些演员换上了盛装，有些则没有。迈克尔和卡洛尔带着对这个派对完全不同的理解走了进来。迈克尔显然告诉过卡洛尔
that this is a costume party so she arrives dressed as a cheerleader. With pom poms. With pom poms. And Michael has his old Halloween costume on. He has his paper mache head. We had a fan question from Melinda O'Brien. Was Michael's costume the same one from the Halloween episode
这是一个化妆舞会，所以她穿着拉拉队的服装来了。手里拿着拉拉队彩球。手里拿着拉拉队彩球。而迈克尔穿着他以前的万圣节服装。他戴着那个纸浆面具头套。我们收到了来自梅琳达·奥布赖恩（Melinda O'Brien）的粉丝提问。迈克尔的服装是万圣节那一集里的同一套吗
or did they have to make another one? Oh no, Melinda, we save everything. Everything that anyone wore or held or used or interacted with on the office goes into a giant warehouse. It's tagged. It's almost like an evidence room. So when they wrote that into this episode,
还是他们得重新做一个？哦不，梅琳达，我们把所有东西都保留了下来。办公室里任何人穿过、拿过、用过或互动过的所有东西都会被送进一个巨大的仓库。它们都贴了标签。几乎就像一个证物室。所以当编剧把这个写进剧本时，
they just went to that warehouse and they picked up that paper mache head and put it right on his shoulder again. That's right. It's like the end of Raiders of the Lost Ark. It's like rows and rows of boxes with dates, tags, episode names. So they went right to that box
他们只要去那个仓库把那个纸浆面具头套拿出来，重新戴到他肩膀上就行了。没错。就像《夺宝奇兵》的结尾。就像一排排贴着日期、标签、剧集名称的箱子。所以他们径直走向那个箱子。
and of course Michael, you know, he can take the head off and then he just looks like he's in a suit but Carol is stuck now as a cheerleader because Michael thought this was Indian Halloween. Yes, I know. Poor Carol. She is such a sport in this episode.
当然迈克尔，你知道的，他可以把头套拿下来，然后看起来就好像只是穿着西装，但卡洛尔现在却被困在拉拉队员的造型里出不去了，因为迈克尔以为这是印度的万圣节。对啊，我懂。可怜的卡洛尔。她在这一集里表现得真是太豁达了。
She has to endure so much. And Nancy Krill just knocked it out of the park. She plays it so perfect of just sort of like quietly enduring this awkward evening while dressed like a cheerleader. Yeah. Well, let's move over to the buffet. Angela's at the buffet.
她必须忍受那么多的尴尬。南希·克里尔（Nancy Krill）演得简直太棒了。她把那种穿着拉拉队服却默默忍受着这个尴尬夜晚的感觉演得惟妙惟肖。好吧，让我们转到自助餐区。安吉拉正在自助餐区。
She asks if they have any vegetarian options. She doesn't even seem satisfied when she learns that everything is vegetarian. It's all vegetarian. She's just in full grump mode. She's like, just give me some bread. And then the guy hands her the bread with his hands. And Angela, you have a line here
她问有没有素食选择。当她得知所有东西都是素食时，她看起来甚至都不满意。全都是素食。她完全进入了满腹牢骚的模式。她就像是，随便给我点面包吧。然后那个人直接用手把面包递给了她。安吉拉，你在这里有句台词
that I am fairly certain you improvised. Oh yeah. I say, can you use your hands as I walk away? And I did improvise that because the guy literally did hand it to me with his hands. And I thought, that's not good. You shouldn't use some tongs. Some tongs.
我敢打包票那是你即兴发挥的。哦对。我说，你能用手拿吗？当我都快走开了。我确实是即兴发挥的，因为那个人真的是用手把面包递给我的。我想，这可不行。你应该用个夹子夹。用夹子。
He just handed it to me with his hands. And so I improvised that line and it stayed in and it makes me laugh. Of course she goes ahead and eats it. So I guess she's not too concerned. But it's clearly she's just like not having a good time. And she's a little like grossed out because she's seeing a lot of feet.
他直接用手把面包递给我。所以我即兴说了那句台词，结果被保留了下来，这让我每次想起来都觉得好笑。当然她还是吃下去了。所以我想她其实也没那么介意。但很显然她就是觉得玩得不开心。而且她有点觉得恶心，因为她看到到处都是光脚，
And now a guy just handed her bread with his hands. A stranger. Well, in the script, it says that you take a bite and say, ugh, garlic. We had some fan questions about the foods. Stacy and Rutby both wrote in to say, was any of that delicious looking buffet food real? Did you get to sample some of the cuisine
现在又有个家伙直接用手把面包递给了她。一个陌生人。好吧，剧本里写的是你咬了一口然后说，呃，好大的蒜味。我们收到了一些关于食物的粉丝提问。斯黛西和鲁特比（Stacy and Rutby）都写信来问，自助餐桌上那些看起来很好吃的食物是真的吗？拍摄这一集时你们有机会品尝那些美食吗？
while filming this episode? Guys, it was all real food. It was all real, it was all delicious. Kent told me we hired a specialty food stylist to create the food that it was authentically prepared and we had it all three days of filming and we got to eat it. And I remember that it was delicious.
伙计们，那全都是真食物。全都是真的，而且全都很美味。金托告诉我，我们聘请了专门的食物造型师来制作这些食物，确保它们是地道做出来的，我们在拍摄的三天里一直都有这些吃的，而且我们真的吃到了。我记得真的很好吃。
It was delicious. I only got to eat the naan, but it was very good naan. Oh, I ate between takes. I just ate it. You don't even see Pam eating it on screen. I was like, I will eat this. Well, now we come to one of the moments in this episode that is one of my favorites, Angela.
太好吃了。我只吃到了馕饼，但那馕饼真的很好吃。哦，我在拍摄间隙一直在吃。我直接就吃了。你在屏幕上甚至都看不到帕姆在吃。我当时的想法是，我一定要把这个吃光。好吧，现在我们迎来了这一集中我最喜欢的时刻之一，安吉拉。
This is when Ryan meets Kelly's giggly sisters. Yeah. It's so, so cute. We got some fan questions from Lindsay Bridget and Dan who all wanna know, do you know what Kelly's sister is saying when they're talking to Ryan? They're saying something about Zach Braff. Okay, here's what the three little girls say.
这就是瑞恩遇到凯莉那些咯咯笑着的妹妹们的场景。对。太可爱了，太可爱了。我们收到了来自林赛、布里奇特和丹的粉丝提问，他们都想知道，当凯莉的妹妹们和瑞恩说话时，她们到底在说什么？她们在说关于扎克·布拉夫（Zach Braff）的事。好的，这三个小女孩是这么说的。
They say, Kelly likes Zach Braff. That's what they're saying in Hindi. And they're sort of like teasing him. They were so cute and they were played by Tanvir Atwal, Ananya Keper and Jayshia Patel. Well, the little girl who plays Kelly's sister that says the Zach Braff line, that's Jayshia. I found her on Instagram and I reached out to her
她们说，凯莉喜欢扎克·布拉夫。她们是用印地语说的。她们在某种程度上是在逗他。她们太可爱了，分别由坦维尔·阿特瓦尔（Tanvir Atwal）、阿纳尼亚·凯珀（Ananya Keper）和杰西亚·帕特尔（Jayshia Patel）饰演。扮演凯莉妹妹、说出扎克·布拉夫这句台词的小女孩就是杰西亚。我在Instagram上找到了她，并联系了她，
to ask her about what it was like to be on the show and she wrote back. I can't wait to share. She must be like a grown lady now. She is a grown woman now. She told me she was 13 years old when she shot this episode. She said she had not really heard about the show.
向她打听参演这部剧是什么体验，她回信了。我迫不及待想和大家分享。她现在一定已经是个成熟的大姑娘了。她现在确实是个成年女性了。她告诉我，她拍这一集的时候才13岁。她说她之前并没有怎么听说过这部剧。
She was still watching Disney Channel, she said. But she said her dad took her to the audition and she remembers walking into the casting office and just seeing tons of other kids who were all there for the same role. And she said the audition was just her saying that one line in Hindi. And she said she didn't speak any Hindi.
她当时还在看迪士尼频道（Disney Channel），她说。但她爸爸带她去参加了试镜，她记得自己走进选角办公室时，看到周围全是为了同一个角色而来的其他小孩。她说试镜内容就是让她用印地语说那一句台词。而她说她根本不会说印地语。
So her dad told her how to say it about five seconds before she went into the audition room and then she got the part. So she said she was so excited and I asked her what it was like to be on set if she had any memories and she sent back the sweetest message. So we're gonna play it for you now.
所以她爸爸在进试镜房间前大约五秒钟教了她怎么说，然后她就拿到这个角色了。所以她说她当时超级兴奋，我问她待在片场是什么感觉，有没有什么回忆，她回了一条超级温馨的信息。所以我们现在把它放给你们听。
I remember Rainn Wilson walking up to me and shoving a lightsaber in my hand and yelling lightsaber war. I also remember getting to know Mindy Kaling and BJ Novak who were so sweet to me. Meeting Mindy Kaling really meant a lot to me growing up because I didn't really see many Indian actresses in the entertainment industry at that time.
我记得雷恩·威尔逊朝我走过来，把一把光剑塞进我手里，大喊光剑大战。我还记得和敏迪·卡灵以及BJ·诺瓦克相处的情景，他们对我都特别好。在成长过程中，能遇到敏迪·卡灵对我有很深远的意义，因为当时我在娱乐圈里真的没怎么见过多少印度裔女演员。
And I love what Mindy has done with her platform and she is still a huge inspiration for me till this day. I also remember all of the delicious Indian food on set and getting to dance all day. And I remember being so happy that I had the chance to wear my Indian clothes. Isn't that so sweet? And that is wonderful.
我非常喜欢敏迪利用她的平台所做的一切，直到今天她依然是我巨大的灵感源泉。我还记得片场所有美味的印度菜，以及一整天都在跳舞。我还记得能有机会穿上我的印度传统服装，我感到特别开心。是不是超级温馨？太美妙了。
That as I listened to it, I was just smiling so big because that is everything about that message is lovely. I love all of her memories. She's absolutely right about Mindy and what Mindy has done. And she's such an inspiration to so many people. Yes, yeah. She told me after the episode aired
当我听这段录音时，我脸上露出了灿烂的笑容，因为那条信息里的一切都太美好了。我喜欢她所有的回忆。关于敏迪以及敏迪所做过的事，她完全没有说错。她确实是那么多人的灵感女神。是的，是的。她告诉我，这一集播出后，
she had classmates and family members reaching out that they had recorded it and taking pictures of her name in the credits. So that was when she was 13. She really wanted to be an actress. She said when she was 15, she decided she wanted to go into journalism. And now Jayshia is the morning news reporter at NBC 15
她的同学们和家人都联系她，说他们把这一集录了下来，还拍下了演职员表里她的名字。那是她13岁的时候。她真的很想成为一名演员。她说她15岁时决定要从事新闻行业。而现在，杰西亚是阿拉巴马州莫尔比市NBC 15台（NBC 15 in Mobile, Alabama）的早间新闻记者。
in Mobile, Alabama. She told me she has to go to bed at four o'clock in the afternoon because she has to be in the studio at 3.30 in the morning. I have always heard that about these morning anchors on the East Coast that they have to get up so early. That's amazing though, Jayshia.
她告诉我，她下午四点就得睡觉，因为她凌晨三点半就得进演播室。我一直听说东海岸的这些早间新闻主播都必须起得这么早。不过这太酷了，杰西亚。
That is so cool. Isn't that so cool? She said all her coworkers know about her appearance on the office and that fans will mention to her because she's Indian. They'll mention the Diwali episode and then she always like blows their mind when she says, oh no, I was in it.
这真是太酷了。是不是超酷的？她说她的同事们都知道她客串过《办公室》，粉丝们因为她是印度裔而向她提起时，总会提到排灯节那一集，每当她随口说出“哦不，其实我演了那一集”时，总是会把粉丝们震惊到。
So I thought that was so sweet. I was in it. I say a line that offends Ryan the temp. Yes, exactly. Except he doesn't quite know he's being the butt of a joke. But she said being on the office was one of her most memorable moments of her childhood.
所以我觉这真的太温馨了。我演了那一集。我说了一句台词，冒犯了临时工瑞恩。没错。只不过他还没完全意识到自己成了笑话里的靶子。但她说能参演《办公室》是她童年最难忘的时刻之一。
I also love that, you know, I'm sure Rain improvised going up to her with that lightsaber. There's a bunch of deleted scenes where he's fighting with kids with lightsabers. And it didn't make it in, but he, Rain looked very much in his element. Like that's how he bonds with children.
我也觉得，我敢肯定雷恩拿着光剑走向她是即兴发挥的。有一堆被删减的片段都是他跟小孩们用光剑打闹。虽然没剪进正片里，但雷恩看起来完全乐在其中。那就是他跟小孩子们打成一片的方式。
Yes. Angela, should we check in on those folks at Stanford, see how they're doing? You mean the folks drinking Jagermeister? Yeah, how are they? And Angela, did you see what they ordered for dinner? Oh, Jenna, you and I know firsthand. You do not drink a lot of alcohol and only eat sushi.
好了，安吉拉，我们要不要去看看斯坦福的那帮人，看看他们过得怎么样？你是说那些喝着野格利口酒的人？对，他们怎么样了？安吉拉，你看到他们晚饭点什么了吗？哦，珍娜，你我都深有体会。你可不能一边喝大量酒精一边只吃寿司。
Now, Angela, why do we know that firsthand? We know that because at the Golden Globes, was it the Golden Globes, Jenna? Oh, lady, I was thinking of my Bachelorette party that you planned for me. Oh, well, there was the Golden Globes, but the Bachelorette? Wait, have we repeated this mistake multiple times?
好了，安吉拉，我们为什么会深有体会？我们知道是因为在金球奖上，那是金球奖吗，珍娜？哦，女士，我当时在想你为我策划的单身派对呢。哦，好吧，是有金球奖，但单身派对？等等，我们难道把这个糗事重复过好多次吗？
Except the second time I did better. The first time it did not work out well for me. The second time, if memory serves, sorry to say this on here, but it hit your sister pretty hard. Yeah, guys, Angela planned a Bachelorette party for me when I was getting married to Lee and she took us all out for her sushi dinner.
不过第二次我吸取教训了。第一次结果对我来说可不太妙。第二次的话，如果我没记错的话，不好意思在这里说出来，但这把你的妹妹折腾得够呛。是的，伙计们，当我准备嫁给李的时候，安吉拉为我策划了一个单身派对，她带我们所有人去吃寿司晚餐。
It was a fancy schmancy sushi place in Beverly Hills that I'd never eaten at, I'd only dreamed of. And I was like, can we go there for my Bachelorette? They were thrilled to have us. It was so cute. All of the ladies from the office were there. All of my other friends were there. And afterwards, you took us to a dance club.
那是比佛利山庄一家超级奢华的寿司店，我以前只敢梦想去那里吃，从来没吃过。当时我说，我们能去那里办我的单身派对吗？他们非常高兴能接待我们。太可爱了。办公室里的所有女士都在那儿。我所有的其他朋友也都在那儿。之后，你带我们去了家舞厅。
Hold up, lady, we're gonna get this right. First of all, the sushi place was your idea. And then after the sushi place, you guys, I got cupcakes with her face on it. It was so cute. We had lots of free drinks sent over. The restaurant was very kind and lots of great sushi. And then after the dinner, I was like,
等等，女士，我们得把这事弄清楚。首先，寿司店是你的主意。然后吃完寿司后，伙计们，我还定制了印有她脸的纸杯蛋糕呢。太可爱了。餐厅给我们送了很多免费饮品，人非常好，寿司也特别棒。然后晚饭后我说，
well, thank you guys and Jenna was like, what's next? And I was like, uh, what? Wait, what? Is this true? I do not remember this. No, lady. All I had planned was the dinner. I didn't plan anything after.
那谢谢大家啦，然后珍娜就问，接下来去哪？我就说，呃，什么？等等，什么？这是真的吗？我完全不记得了。不，女士。我当时只计划了晚饭。我根本没计划后面的事。
Is this the first time you're ever hearing of this? Yes. This is putting the dance club into perspective now. Cause I thought at the time it was an odd choice cause we've never in a million years gone clubbing. And now we were suddenly clubbing for my bachelorette, but I was like, this is great. What a fun idea.
这是你第一次听说这事吗？是的。这让那个舞厅的经历变得有意义了。因为当时我觉得那是个奇怪的选择，我们有一百万年都不可能去夜店蹦迪。而我们当时却突然为了我的单身派对去蹦迪了，但我当时还觉得，太棒了。多有趣的主意啊。
Yeah, I should say, you guys, we had a car. I got one of the big limos, you know, that we could all pile in. And I called a friend of mine who was like, always kind of like, got, you know, you have that one friend that's like, I got a hookup. I got a hookup. Yeah, I'm in the know.
好吧，我得说，伙计们，我们租了一辆车。我租了一辆大加长轿车，你知道的，我们能一窝蜂挤进去那种。我给我一个朋友打了个电话，那个人属于那种，总是好像，你知道的，你有那种朋友，号称“我有人脉，我有人脉”。对，我消息很灵通。
I called my friend Tess and I was like, Tess. I, Jenna wants to go dancing. I were in Beverly Hills. What do I do? What do I do? And she was like, I'm on it. Give me like five, 10 minutes. I said, okay.
我打电话给我的朋友苔丝（Tess）说，苔丝。我，珍娜想去跳舞。我们在比佛利山庄。我该怎么做？我该怎么做？她说，包在我身上。给我五到十分钟。我说，好的。
So we kind of hung out a little bit. And I was like, um, I'm starting out some stuff guys. I do remember hanging out on the sidewalk outside the. Yes. It's because I didn't have a plan. Cause the restaurant. All I had planned for was fancy sushi. And our evening would have been over at like 10 o'clock.
所以我们在那儿闲逛了一会儿。我就开始觉得，呃，大家，我好像在搞砸一些事情。我确实记得我们当时在外面的人行道上闲逛。对。那是因为我根本没做计划。因为餐厅。我唯一的计划就是豪华寿司。而且我们的夜晚本应该在十点左右就结束的。
Yeah. Anyway, I get a call from Tess and she goes, all right, Angela's pretty last minute. It's like, you know, a Thursday night in Beverly Hills. So I did get you in this one club. I know this guy, he's got a booth for you. And they're going to give you drink service. It's kind of a random club, but it'll be fun.
不管怎样，我接到了苔丝的电话，她说，好了，安吉拉这安排得太临时了。这可是比佛利山庄的周四晚上啊。不过我确实给你订了一家夜店。我认识个老板，他给你们留了一个卡座。他们会给你们提供瓶装酒服务。那家夜店虽然有点随性，但应该挺好玩的。
You guys can dance. Angela, it's the only time I've ever experienced bottle service. Bottle service is where you like, they bring you just bottles of alcohol and then mixers and like little cut lines to your table and you make your drinks. Also when they walk it over, everyone starts doing, at least for us, I think this was the norm cause I would see different people get bottle service.
你们可以去跳舞。安吉拉，那是我这辈子第一次体验瓶装酒服务。瓶装酒服务就是，他们会直接拿几瓶烈酒到你们桌上，然后还有调酒饮料和切好的小配菜，你们自己调酒。而且当他们把酒端过来时，所有人都会开始，至少对我们来说，我觉得这是常态，因为我看到其他人享受瓶装酒服务时也是这样。
And it was like, they shut off like Fetty in the air. It was so weird. It was so bizarre. They had, it was crazy dancing. I remember we got in trouble because we were dancing on top of the couches and we got reprimanded for that. But guys, on our stomachs of sushi mixed with bottle service long story short, at the end of the night
现场就像是在空中放礼花一样。太诡异了。太离谱了。他们有，那种跳舞太疯狂了。我记得我们因为站在沙发上跳舞而惹上了麻烦，还被训斥了一顿。但伙计们，由于我们胃里混合了寿司和大量的酒，长话短说，那天深夜
as the limo is dropping everyone off, my sister puked in Ellie Kemper's bushes. I puked when I got home, it was in my hair. I slept in it. It was an epic night, but that's what you get when you mix sushi and a lot of booze. And that is what is in store for these guys in Stamford. Yeah, as Jenna and I rewatched this episode,
当加长轿车把大家一一送回家时，我妹妹在艾丽·坎珀（Ellie Kemper）家的灌木丛里吐了。我到家后也吐了，吐在了自己头发上。我在那一头呕吐物里睡着了。那真是一个史诗级的夜晚，但这就是你把寿司和大量美酒混在一起的下场。而这也是等待着斯坦福那帮人的命运。是的，当珍娜和我重看这一集时，
I texted her and I was like, oh, lady, alcohol, and sushi, it's so true. It is so true. Should we go back to Diwali because Roy has arrived and he is watching Pam dance and have fun. And I have a full Mindy catch for you right here. You do? And we've got a sting for it and everything.
我给发短信她说，哦，女士，酒精加寿司，真是太真实了。太真实了。我们要不要回到排灯节现场，因为罗伊已经到了，他正看着帕姆跳舞玩得很开心。我这里正好有一个完整的敏迪梗要送给你。真的吗？我们连音效都准备好了，应有尽有。
What? Full Mindy. There you go. It's a full Mindy catch. Mira During wrote in to say at the Diwali party when Roy walks in, Beyonce's crazy in love is playing in the background. And Angela, this was a note in the script.
什么？完整的敏迪梗。给你。这就是完整的敏迪梗。米拉·杜林（Mira During）写信说，在排灯节派对上罗伊走进来的时候，背景音乐放的是碧昂斯的《Crazy in Love》。安吉拉，这是剧本里的一处备注。
Mindy wrote in what song would be playing when Roy walks in and that it would be a Beyonce song. So I think this is a full, full Mindy. I love it. It's a very subtle full Mindy. It's like full Mindy when you don't even see Mindy, but her presence is still there. Exactly.
敏迪在剧本里写了罗伊进场时应该放什么歌，而且必须是一首碧昂斯的歌。所以我认为这是一个纯正的、完整的敏迪梗。我太喜欢了。这是一个非常隐蔽的完整敏迪梗。就像即使你看不到敏迪，但她的存在感依然无处不在。没错。
And you know, my dance partner, we talked about this in the interview with Mindy, my dance partner, Vali. Okay. He was well-known by the writers because he was a writer on My Name is Earl at the time. And he went on to write on 30 Rock and was one of the executive producers of Modern Family. Oh my gosh.
你知道的，我的舞伴，我们在采访敏迪时聊过，我的舞伴瓦利（Vali）。好的。编剧们对他非常熟悉，因为他当时是《愚人善事》（My Name is Earl）的编剧。他后来还去给《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）写过剧本，并且是《摩登家庭》（Modern Family）的执行制片人之一。天哪。
I know. Well, that Mindy did say, guys, he wasn't an actor. He was like a friend of ours. That's so funny. A friend of ours, that's so wild. Well, can I ask you a little bit about your dance moves there, Ms. Fisher? You can.
我知道。好吧，敏迪确实说过，伙计们，他不是演员。他就是我们的一个朋友。太搞笑了。我们的朋友，这太疯狂了。好吧，费舍尔女士，我能向你打听一下你在那里的舞姿吗？可以。
What are you gonna say? I've danced with you. And I can tell you right now, folks, that was not a choreographed dance routine. That was just Jenna being Jenna. Yeah. We had a fan question from Zaria Collins who asked that same question.
你打算说什么？我和你跳过舞。我可以现在就告诉大家，伙计们，那绝对不是排音编排好的舞蹈动作。那纯粹就是珍娜在做她自己。是的。我们收到了来自扎里亚·柯林斯（Zaria Collins）的粉丝提问，她问的正是这个问题。
Were those dance moves choreographed? Oh no. Oh no. That's all Ms. Fisher. That's me fully dancing with my heart and soul. That's hello, St. Louis. St. Louis prom. That sounds a Scranton right there.
那些舞蹈动作是排练过的吗？哦不。哦不。那全都是费舍尔女士的自由发挥。那完全是我用心灵和灵魂在跳舞。那是，你好啊，圣路易斯。圣路易斯舞会。听起来就像斯克兰顿风格。
That's the same girl who made a sounds of Scranton playlist, everyone. There I am. You could almost rewind me and put me in my high school gym right there. Well, something is gonna happen that is super awkward because that is Michael's way. Michael's way is to take a wonderful moment
大家注意，她就是那个制作了“斯克兰顿之声”播放列表的女孩。我就是这样。你几乎可以倒带把我放回我高中的体育馆里。好吧，接下来会发生一件超级尴尬的事，因为这就是迈克尔的风格。迈克尔的风格就是把一个美好的时刻
and make everyone cringe. And the Diwali was going to be no exception. He has this amazing scene with Mindy's parents that play Kelly's parents, which we already talked about. And he's so inspired by their love. He's gonna do it. He's gonna do it. Their commitment.
搞得让所有人都尴尬得脚趾抠地。排灯节也不例外。他和扮演凯莉父母的敏迪的父母有一场精彩的对手戏，我们刚才已经聊过了。他被他们的爱深深打动了。他要这么做了。他要这么做了。被他们的承诺打动了。
He's gonna propose to Carol in front of a whole room of strangers on their ninth date. Yes, she's like, Carol, will you do me the honor of making me your husband? Of making me your husband. And she's like, can we talk about this in private? And this is one of my favorite moments in movies and TV
他要在第九次约会时，当着满屋子陌生人的面向卡洛尔求婚。是的，他说的是，卡洛尔，你愿意给我这个荣幸，让我成为你的丈夫吗？让我成为你的丈夫。然后卡洛尔说，我们能私下谈谈吗？这是电影和电视中最让我喜欢的时刻之一
where he's like, what? Into a microphone. She's like, can we talk about it in private? And then he's like, oh man, oh crap. Well, they have this scene out in the parking lot, Jenna. And it made me laugh so hard that, you know, Carol is like, I can't do this, Michael. I can't do it.
他居然对着话筒大喊，什么？她接着说，我们能私下谈谈吗？然后他说，哦天哪，哦糟糕。好吧，他们在停车场有一场戏，珍娜。这让我笑得前仰后合，你知道的，卡洛尔当时说，我做不到，迈克尔。我真的做不到。
And his last ditch effort, his last few moments, what is he gonna say that might change her mind? He's gonna go for it. What could he say to change this woman's mind? Do you know what he says? Let me come with you. I have this book, the Kamasutra. She says, exactly.
在他最后的绝望尝试中，在最后的几分钟里，他会说些什么来改变她的心意呢？他要孤注一掷了。他能说些什么来改变这个女人的心意呢？你知道他说什么吗？让我跟你一起去。我有一本书，叫《爱经》。她说，没错。
She's like, good night, Michael. Well, at this point, Pam is, she's talking to Valley and she's realizing something. She wants to reach out to Jim. So she's gonna text Jim. Well, that thing happened. That thing happened, which is, you know, this crazy moment just happened
她就像是在说，晚安，迈克尔。好吧，此时帕姆正在和瓦利说话，她意识到了一件事。她想联系吉姆。所以她要给吉姆发短信。好吧，那件事发生了。那件事发生了，也就是，你知道的，这个疯狂的时刻刚刚发生
and who does she wanna share it with, right? This is how you know you really care about someone. Your person out there, folks, is the person you wanna tell everything to right after it happens. It's who you bounce everything off of and Pam wants to tell her person what just happened. But she runs into Angela.
而她想和谁分享呢，对吧？这就是你怎么知道你真的很在乎一个人。大伙儿，你在外面那个人，就是事情发生后你最想把一切都告诉他的那个人。那是你拿所有事情去商量的人，帕姆想把刚刚发生的事告诉她心里的那个人。但她遇到了安吉拉。
She needs to get her shoes and there is Angela guarding the shoes, she says. Well, and eating her dry naan. By the way, Angela, fan question from Rainey Gregg. Was the naan dry? No. Was it actually dry? No, it wasn't.
她得去拿她的鞋子，安吉拉正守在那里看着鞋子，她说。好吧，还在吃她的干馕。顺便说一句，安吉拉，蕾妮·格雷格（Rainey Gregg）的一个粉丝提问。馕是干的吗？没有。实际上是干的吗？没有，不是的。
It was perfectly fine. No, I would say that too. I ate some of that naan. It was wonderful. I was glad to have it. I was probably hungry. Well, Jen and I used to always get so tickled to have scenes together,
它非常好。不，我也会那么说。我吃了一些那个馕。它棒极了。我很高兴能吃到它。我可能饿了。好吧，詹和我以前总是对能一起拍戏感到非常高兴，
because it rarely happened. So we were really excited about this. I loved shooting this scene with you and I love it so much. I just want us to play it. Sam, can you play it? It's hot in there. How's the naan?
因为这种事很少发生。所以我们对此真的非常兴奋。我爱极了和你一起拍这场戏，我太喜欢了。我只希望我们把它演出来。萨姆，你能放一下吗？里面好热。馕怎么样？
Dry. Looked like you were having fun. I am. You should come dance with us. I have to watch our shoes so they don't get stolen. Who are you texting? No one. But also, lady, my character is so nosy.
干的。看起来你玩得很开心。我是。你应该过来和我们一起跳舞。我得看着我们的鞋子免得它们被偷了。你在给谁发短信？没谁。但话说回来，女士，我的角色太爱打听了。
So nosy. Who are you texting? Yeah, it looked like you were having fun. Who are you texting? I mean, who am I to ask you who you're texting? You're the party police. Also, you're single. Dwight made this big announcement that he's single.
太爱打听了。你在给谁发短信？对啊，看起来你玩得很开心。你在给谁发短信？我是说，我算老几，凭什么问你在给谁发短信？你是派对警察。另外，你单身。德怀特发布了重大声明，说他单身。
I don't know. Maybe you're texting Dwight. What's happening? Angela's spinning out in this episode and a lot of those scenes ended up getting deleted, but it would be a fun watch to go back and watch them because that is why you are so intense in this episode. So now Pam is gonna make it outside.
我不知道。也许你在给德怀特发短信。怎么回事？安吉拉在这个剧集里情绪失控了，很多这样的场景最后都被删掉了，但回过头去看它们会是一件很有趣的事，因为这就是为什么你在这一集里情绪这么激烈。所以现在帕姆要走到外面去了。
She hasn't received a text back from Jim and she sits with Michael. Michael tries to relate to her. He's like, wow, they're both victims of broken engagements. And Pam's like, well, I mean, except that you were never actually engaged, but whatever. She tries to bond with Michael. And of course, he does that thing
她没有收到吉姆的回信，她和迈克尔坐在一起。迈克尔试图和她感同身受。他就像是，哇，他们俩都是破碎婚约的受害者。帕姆就觉得，好吧，我是说，除了你其实从来没订过婚之外，但随便吧。她试着和迈克尔拉近关系。当然，他做了那件事
that you were just talking about where he just takes it one step too far and he starts to lean in like he's gonna kiss her. So awkward. We got a lot of mail about it, Angela. Ruby, Alexandra and Vanessa Ortiz all wrote in to ask if that was a scripted moment when Michael tries to kiss Pam, what was it like?
就是你刚才说的，他做得太过头了，他开始往前倾，就像要吻她一样。太尴尬了。我们收到了很多关于它的邮件，安吉拉。鲁比、亚历山大和凡妮莎·奥尔蒂斯都写信来问，当迈克尔试图亲吻帕姆时，那是剧本里写好的吗，当时是什么情况？
It was scripted, you guys. That was in the script. And then the thing, that great line that Pam has where she says, I'm rejecting your kiss. He's like, she's like, what are you doing? He's like, what are you doing? She's like, I'm rejecting your kiss. That's what I'm doing.
那是剧本里写好的，各位。那在剧本里。然后那件事，帕姆那句绝妙的台词，她说，我拒绝你的吻。他就像是，她就像是，你在干什么？他就像是，你在干什么？她就像是，我拒绝你的吻。这就是我在做的事。
Yeah, what are you doing? That was all scripted. And Angela, I was so excited to do that scene because I remember staying late that evening and shooting outside. I talked about this before when I had that scene with John up on the roof where Pam and Jim eat the grilled cheese sandwiches, it was one of those warm summer evenings
是的，你在干什么？那全都是剧本写的。安吉拉，我当时太兴奋能演那场戏了，因为我记得那天晚上很晚还在外面拍摄。我以前说过，我和约翰在屋顶拍帕姆和吉姆吃烤奶酪三明治的那场戏时，那是洛杉矶一个温暖的夏夜，
in Los Angeles, they're the best. This was another one of those. And it's one of my fondest memories from shooting the show because I got Steve all to myself and I got Miguel Arte to all to myself and Mindy was there and it was just us doing the scene, getting it just perfect. It felt like we had all the time in the world.
那种感觉太棒了。这是另一个那样的夜晚。这是我拍摄这部剧最美好的回忆之一，因为我一个人独占了史蒂夫，我一个人独占了米格尔·阿尔特（Miguel Arte），明迪也在那儿，只有我们几个在拍这场戏，把它做到尽善尽美。感觉我们拥有世上所有的宏大时间。
There was no rush and I just absolutely loved it. Yeah, well Mindy mentioned that she was kind of jealous of her parents that they got to have this great scene with Steve because there are several characters, myself included, that rarely got to have one-on-one scenes with Steve. It just wouldn't make sense in the world of the show. And whenever I did, it felt so special
一点也不匆忙，我绝对爱极了。是的，明迪提到过，她有点嫉妒她的父母，因为他们能和史蒂夫有这么棒的一场戏，因为有几个角色，包括我在内，很少能有机会和史蒂夫单独对戏。在这个剧的世界里那根本说不通。每当我能有这样的机会时，都觉得特别珍贵，
and I think you got to have some amazing scenes with him throughout the course of the show and this is just one of those that was just beautiful and so fun and funny and cringy and heartfelt, just all of it. That's all true. Angela, we did have someone right in with an old tech alert that I thought you would appreciate.
而且我觉得在整部剧的过程中，你和有过一些非常棒的对手戏，这只是其中之一，它那么美妙、那么有趣、那么好玩、那么尴尬又那么走心，所有这些全都有。这全都是真的。安吉拉，我们确实有人写信来提到了一个老科技警报，我想你会喜欢的。
Hit me up, how'd I miss it? What is it? Kayla Whitehead said Pam's cell phone. Oh yeah. It's such old tech, but she's like, but also when she walks outside, Michael sees her on the steps and he notices that she's holding her phone and he says expecting a call.
说吧，我怎么会错过？是什么？凯拉·怀特黑德（Kayla Whitehead）说帕姆的手机。哦，对。这是这么老旧的科技，但她就像是，不过当她走到外面时，迈克尔看到她在台阶上，他注意到她手里拿着手机，他说在等电话吗？
She was like, no one would say that to you today. If you have your phone in your hand today, no one's like expecting a call because we always all have our phones in our hand. That is a brilliant catch. I am applauding that catch. I love that observation. That is an amazing observation because back then,
她就像是，现在没人会那样对你说话。如果你今天手里拿着手机，没人会觉得像是在等电话，因为我们总是人手一部手机。这是一个绝妙的发现。我为这个发现鼓掌。我喜欢这个观察。这是一个了不起的观察，因为在当时，
yeah, your phone was in your purse. We didn't walk around holding phones like flip phones like that because we did hardly anything with them other than talk to someone. So if you're holding it, you'd probably just spoke to someone or you were about to. Yes.
是的，你的手机放在钱包里。我们不会像那样拿着翻盖手机到处走，因为除了跟人通话之外，我们几乎用它们干不了什么。所以如果你拿着它，你可能刚跟人通完话，或者正准备打。是的。
That is a great observation. Pretty great. Well, I wanna take us back to Stanford because I think there is a moment in this episode that is the happiest we have seen Andy since he has appeared on the show. It's happy Andy and I wanna share happy Andy with you. Happy Andy happens at around 15 minutes.
这是一个很棒的观察。相当棒。好吧，我想带大家回到斯坦福，因为我觉得这一集里有一个时刻，是自从安吉拉出现在剧里以来，我们见过的最开心的安吉拉。不对，是开心的安迪，我想和大家分享开心的安迪。开心的安迪出现在大约15分钟的时候。
They have had a lot of Yeager. Karen though, she's just tossing her Yeager shots into the trash. No one knows it. She's not getting wasted. And Andy starts singing acapella. Karen's like, no acapella Andy, but he's drunk and he's singing.
他们喝了很多野格酒。不过凯伦，她只是把她的野格酒倒进垃圾桶里。没人知道。她没有喝得烂醉。然后安迪开始清唱。凯伦就像是，不要清唱安迪，但他喝醉了还在唱。
The indigo girl's closer to fine. And as he drunkenly sings, all of a sudden Jim who's super wasted starts joining in and singing. And it's so adorable. Andy's like, tuna, are you kidding me? Like, he's so happy. He's so happy.
靛蓝女孩（The Indigo Girls）的《更完美》（Closer to Fine）。当他醉醺醺地唱着时，突然超级烂醉的吉姆开始加入进来一起唱。太可爱了。安吉拉就像是，金枪鱼，你在开玩笑吗？你看，他太开心了。他太开心了。
They're having like an acapella moment. And this is happy Andy. He is thrilled. Well, Angela, we had a fan catch for Renata Torres. She says at 17 minutes, 58 seconds, you can see a pair of white flip flops under Karen's death. Ah! And she wanted to know if that was on purpose,
他们就像是在进行一个清唱时刻。这就是开心的安迪。他兴奋极了。好吧，安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝雷娜塔·托雷斯（Renata Torres）的发现。她说在17分58秒，你能看到凯伦办公桌下有一双白色夹脚拖鞋。
but we know why those are there. We do, those were Rashida's flip flops. Yeah, the wardrobe department would give us Uggs or flip flops to wear to and from our trailers and set, so we didn't have to walk in our kind of like high heel office shoes, right? Yeah.
啊！她想知道那是故意的吗，但我们知道为什么那些东西会在那儿。我们知道，那是雷西达（Rashida）的夹脚拖鞋。是的，服装部门会给我们UGG或者夹脚拖鞋，让我们穿梭于拖车和片场之间，这样我们就不必穿着那种高跟办公室鞋走路了，对吧？
Yes. You caught Rashida's flip flops. You know, wardrobe actually told me one time also, our trailers were not close to the soundstage. It was a little, you know, quite a walk. And they said that also they would take our shoes to protect our shoes because if we walked across the parking lot back and forth
没错。是的。你发现了雷西达的夹脚拖鞋。你知道，服装部门其实也曾告诉过我一次，我们的拖车离摄影棚不近。那有点，你知道的，要走挺长一段路的。他们说他们也会拿走我们的鞋子来保护我们的鞋子，因为如果我们来回穿过停车场，
and sometimes if there was weather of any kind, they preferred actually to leave our shoes on set by our desks rather than us walking around in them all the time. We were delighted because that meant less time in heels. We had our travel shoes. Those were Rashida's travel shoes. Well, as they're leaving for the night in Stanford,
有时候如果有什么天气状况，他们其实更愿意把我们的鞋子留在片场的办公桌旁，而不是让我们一直穿着它们到处走。我们很高兴，因为这意味着少穿高跟鞋的时间。我们有我们的出行鞋。那是雷西达的出行鞋。好吧，当他们在斯坦福的夜晚准备离开时，
Jim is gonna ride that bike home. He's gonna ride his bike home. Or is he? Well, yeah. He falls over. Well, you know, it's the end of the night at Stanford. They've had Jaeger. They've bonded over Indigo Girls.
吉姆要骑那辆自行车回家。他要骑自行车回家。真的是吗？好吧，是的。他摔倒了。好吧，你知道的，那是斯坦福的夜晚结束时。他们喝了野格酒。他们因靛蓝女孩而增进了感情。
I mean, Andy's busting out his air mattress. He's like. Oh yeah. He's staying in for the night. Jim is gonna try to ride his giant bicycle with the big basket home. And he like tips over into the bushes and Karen's in her car.
我是说，安迪正在搬出他的充气床垫。他就像是。哦，对。他今晚要留下来。吉姆要试着骑他那辆带大筐的巨大自行车回家。结果他一头栽进了灌木丛里，而凯伦在她的车里。
She's like, hold up, get in my car, drunkie. And Jenna, do you remember how freaked out people were about this moment? Yeah. I mean, people thought Karen was shady, that she let them get so wasted and that was she waiting for Jim? Like she had planned it all along.
她就像是，等一下，上我的车，酒鬼。珍娜，你还记得大家对这个时刻有多抓狂吗？是的。我是说，人们觉得凯伦很可疑，她居然让他们喝得这么烂醉，她是在等吉姆吗？就像她一直计划好的一样。
Yeah, was she waiting out in the parking lot for Jim? And I was like, hey, Mr. Tipsy, get in my car. And remember this, in this episode, it was written that they were gonna like kiss. I talked to Rashida about it. I texted with her and I want to read you guys what she said. She said in this episode there,
是的，她是在停车场等吉姆吗？我就像是在说，嘿，微醺先生，上我的车。记住这个，在这一集里，剧本原本写的是他们会接吻。我和雷西达聊过这事。我给她发了短信，我想读给你们听她是怎么说的。她说在这集里，
they had written a scene where Jim and Karen get sloppy drunk and make out. So maybe I guess she had been drinking too in that different version, right? In that different version, because I have the scripted version of that, the three of them go to a bar and they all get drunk together at a bar
他们写过一个场景，吉姆和凯伦喝得烂醉如泥然后热吻。所以也许我想她在那个不同的版本里也喝过酒，对吧？在那个不同版本里，因为我有那个剧本版本，他们三个人去了一个酒吧，他们都在酒吧里喝醉了，
and then they were supposed to make out on the street outside of this bar. And Rashida said they actually filmed the scene in the parking lot. Oh my God. And she said she was really worried, she was like, everyone's gonna hate me. And then she told me Steven Merchant
然后他们本应该在酒吧外面的街道上热吻。雷西达说他们实际上在停车场拍了这场戏。哦天哪。她说她真的很担心，她当时想，每个人都会讨厌我。然后她告诉我史蒂芬·莫昌特（Steven Merchant）
actually suggested that they cut the scene out. That he got to watch of her. Cause Steven and Ricky would watch our episodes and they would give the producers notes rarely, but sometimes and their notes were always correct. They were always like, they knew don't move that needle so far. Yeah. And Rashida said she felt like
其实建议他们把这场戏删掉。因为他一直在关注她。因为史蒂芬和瑞奇会看我们的剧集，他们会给制片人提意见，虽然不常有，但有时会提，而且他们的意见总是对的。他们总是像这样，他们知道别把那根针拨得太远。是的。雷西达说她觉得
Steven really understood the relationships and that this was going too far, too bold, too quickly. And it would sort of sabotage anything that Jim and Karen might, could possibly be as a foil for Pam. It was just too much. Yeah. I think if you wanted to believe in their relationship, which you will,
史蒂芬真的理解这些人际关系，这有点太过头了、太大胆了、太快了。这某种程度上会破坏吉姆和凯伦作为帕姆的对照可能成为的一切。这实在太过分了。是的。我想如果你想相信他们的关系，你会的，
like Jim and Karen are gonna really have a great relationship. You don't want it to start off with like a sloppy drunk make out on the side of the street. Kids, are you listening? Nothing good happens after midnight. Okay, go home.
就像吉姆和凯伦真的会拥有一段很棒的关系。你可不想让它以在街边烂醉如泥的热吻作为开端。孩子们，你们在听吗？午夜过后没有好事发生。好了，回家去。
This is what aunt told me when I went off to college. She said, here's my advice to you about sleeping around. This is what she said. She said, you're gonna go to these parties, you're gonna do some drinking, and you might in the moment wanna make a decision that's impulsive.
这就是我去上大学时我阿姨对我说的话。她说，这是我对你关于乱搞的建议。她是这么说的。她说，你要去参加这些派对，你要喝点酒，你可能会在当时做出一个冲动的决定。
She said, my advice to you is go home because you can always wake up in the morning and say, oh, I wish I'd slept with that guy and you can do something about it. But you can't undo. You can't undo. Yeah. I'm with your aunt. You can't undo.
她说，我对你的建议是回家，因为你总是可以在早晨醒来时说，哦，我真希望我和那个家伙睡了，然后你可以采取行动。但你无法撤销。你无法撤销。是的。我支持你阿姨。你无法撤销。
But I was kind of lame in college. When I turned 21, I had a big paper due for a class I was taking. And all my friends were like, you're gonna go out it's your 21st birthday. And I said, oh, no, I need to work on my paper. So I worked on my paper and my dad had a Texaco gas card and he would pay my Texaco gas card.
但在大学里我有点无趣。当我满21岁时，我有一篇选修课的大论文要交。我的所有朋友都说，你要出去玩，今天是你的21岁生日。我说，哦，不，我得写我的论文。所以我写了我的论文，我爸爸有一张德士古（Texaco）加油卡，他会帮我付德士古加油卡的钱。
Just like reality bites, I would go to that gas station and I would get gas, bread, sandwich, meat, potato chips, soda, like everything. And I went to Texaco and I bought myself a Coronita. It's not even the big Corona. It's a Coronita because I was 21 and I went and I worked on my term paper and I had my Coronita. And that was my 21st birthday.
就像电影《现实咬人》（Reality Bites）里一样，我会去那个加油站加油，买汽油、面包、三明治肉、薯片、苏打水，就像所有东西一样。我去了德士古，给自己买了一瓶小科罗娜（Coronita）。甚至不是大瓶的科罗娜。是一小瓶科罗娜，因为我21岁了，然后我去写我的学期论文，喝着我的小科罗娜。那就是我的21岁生日。
That is literally adorable. That is adorable. I was a big dork lady. That's why we would have been friends. I would have hung out with you and your cat. We would have been besties. This is also why as adults, we mixed sushi with a lot of hard liquor.
这简直太可爱了。这太可爱了。我以前是个超级书呆子，女士。这就是为什么我们会成为朋友。我会和你还有你的猫一起玩。我们会成为好闺蜜的。这也是为什么作为成年人，我们把寿司和大量烈酒混着吃。
Because we didn't learn in college, we didn't learn. Where are we at? I don't even know where we're at except that Karen put Jim in his car. And now we go back to Diwali and it's one of my favorite moments ever. Dwight and Michael are gonna perform a cover of Adam Sandler's Hanukkah song,
因为我们在大学里没学到，我们没学到。我们说到哪了？我甚至不知道我们说到哪了，只知道凯伦把吉姆弄上了车。现在我们回到排灯节，这是我有史以来最喜欢的时刻之一。德怀特和迈克尔将表演亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）的《光明节之歌》的翻唱版，
dedicated to Indians everywhere. Yes, the crowd loves it. Angela, so many people wrote in asking about this song. Was it improvised? A lot of people thought that because Steve was holding a piece of paper that maybe we wrote this on the fly. No, this was in the script.
献给各地的印度人。是的，观众们很喜欢。安吉拉，有这么多人写信来询问这首歌。它是即兴创作的吗？很多人以为因为史蒂夫手里拿着一张纸，所以我们可能是现场临时写的。不，这在剧本里。
And in fact, Kent told me it had been in the script as far back as the pre-table draft. This is kind of a writer's term, but they send out a draft of the script before they let anyone see it and they have to give it to all of the main producers so that they can start planning wardrobe and locations. And Kent said that at that pre-table draft,
事实上，肯特告诉我，早在正式读剧本前的草稿里，它就已经在剧本里了。这算是编剧的一个术语，但他们在让任何人看到之前会发送一份剧本草稿，他们必须把它交给所有的主要制片人，这样他们就可以开始规划服装和外景了。肯特说在那份读剧本前的草稿里，
this was the tag for the episode and it remained there until we shot it. So they got permission and all that kind of stuff. And he said Steve asked for that piece of paper because he felt like his character wrote it at the party. And that would sell the idea that this was like a last minute idea by Michael. Yeah, yeah, I thought the same thing.
这就是这一集的尾声彩蛋，它一直留在那儿直到我们拍摄。所以他们获得了许可之类的东西。他说史蒂夫要那张纸是因为他觉得他的角色是在派对上写下它的。那会卖力兜售这样一个想法：这就像是迈克尔临时起意的一个主意。对，对，我也是这么想的。
I thought Michael needed those notes. Steve did not. Right. Yeah. Well, it's so good and I have a really great catch. I'm gonna call it a BFF catch. What is it? At 20 minutes, 34 seconds,
我觉得迈克尔需要那些纸条。史蒂夫不需要。对。好吧，它太棒了，我有一个非常棒的发现。我要称它为一个闺蜜发现。是什么？在20分钟34秒时，
after he's finished singing and it pans to the crowd and everyone cheers, you and I are sitting side by side on the floor together. Oh my gosh, Angela, you know we did that ourselves. I know, we sat together, we probably were, I mean, I remember them doing that song. We were all just elated and along for the ride. It was so fun.
在他唱完之后镜头摇向人群，每个人都在欢呼，你和我并肩坐在地板上。哦天哪，安吉拉，你知道那是我们自己做的事。我知道，我们坐在一起，我们可能，我是说，我记得他们唱那首歌。我们当时都兴高采烈，顺其自然。太有趣了。
And I think we just sat next to each other because they probably weren't even sure if they were gonna use that big swing back to the crowd, right? Yeah. And so there we are, there we are on the ground next to each other, BFF catch. That is the perfect way to end
我想我们只是坐在彼此旁边，因为他们可能甚至不确定是否要使用那个摇回人群的大镜头，对吧？是的。所以我们就坐在那儿，我们并肩坐在地上，闺蜜发现。那是结束
this podcast episode of Diwali. We did it with a BFF catch. We did it and thank you so much to Mindy Kaling for stopping by. I just felt like we could kept talking and talking and I can't wait for her to come back. And if you guys get a chance, go check out Mindy's new show
这期排灯节播客节目的完美方式。我们用一个闺蜜发现来收尾。我们做到了，非常感谢明迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）的光临。我只是觉得我们可以一直说个不停，我等不及她再回来了。如果你们有机会，去看看明迪的新剧吧，
that she co-created with Lang Fisher. It's so cute. It's a coming of age kind of comedy drama called Never Have I Ever and the cast is wonderful and the writing is great. And you guys, if you watch it, you'll see Angela on it because Angela's in it in a couple of episodes.
那是她和朗·费舍尔（Lang Fisher）共同创作的。太可爱了。这是一部成长类型的喜剧剧情片，名叫《好想做一次》（Never Have I Ever），演员阵容很棒，剧本也很棒。各位，如果你们看了，你们会看到安吉拉在里面，因为安吉拉在其中的几集里演了。
Yes, I'm in two episodes. I play the mom. I play one of her nemesis' mom and it was really fun. I'll be the mom all day long, Jenna. I know. Yeah, casting folks out there, if you need a mom with a little bit of sass, give me a call.
对，我在两集里出现。我演妈妈。我演她死对头的妈妈，真的很有趣。珍娜，我整天演妈妈都行。我懂。是的，各位选角导演，如果你需要一个有点傲慢的妈妈，给我打电话。
You know where to go. Guys, thank you so much. This was a really fun one and we will be back next week with Branch Wars. See you then. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf,
你知道去哪找。各位，非常感谢。这一集真的很有趣，我们下周将带着《分部之战》（Branch Wars）回归。到时见。拜拜。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium,
珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡胶树》（Rubber Tree）。想要收听本剧的无广告版本以及我们的彩蛋剧集《糖果袋》（Candy Bag），请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，
use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请使用代码 OFFICE。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。